[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from 14 nations converge in st.
Louis as US chess champs calm presents
the third annual spring chess Classic
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for the final day of action for
the 2019 spring chess classic my name is
Ben Simon and filling in for Grandmaster
Ramon Hamilton is once again
Caleb Denby yesterday it was me today
that's am on but how do you feel being
back in the studio for your second day
it's great to be back you know I'm a
world-class substitute so I'll see what
I can do trying to fill them on shoes
this time instead of the hosts
spectacular yeah we'll see how that
works and if we do have playoff later
this evening we do expect a Mount
Hamilton to join us but this is a this
is a big situation this is one of the
most competitive classic events we've
ever had because no less than four
players can tie for first in putting us
in a potential four-way playoff let's
see how this stacks up with our
standings in Group A now coming into the
round three players tied for first and
agent Robson and Jean but then Aria and
tari of Norway has four and a half
points it's important to note that Eric
Hanson and Liam Lee coming into the
round could not finish first because two
of the five point players Robson and
Zhang are playing each other so still
those top four players we could have a
four-way playoff Caleb yeah we
definitely can and our entire if he
manages to win his game he bumps up to
five and a half and so that's just two
draws from the leaders and we'll
definitely see that playoff going on
yeah it's important to note and you know
where Robson got that victory yesterday
over a Cobian which now propels him back
into into contention all right and in
Group B let's take a look at those
standings and what we thought was could
very well have been a runaway train at
one point with by ginchy it's not so but
he's still the favorite to win we have
two players within
reaching distance of the first-place
prize
Andre baarish bullets looking to repeat
as grupe champion caleb yeah and he was
actually very lucky to get away with a
draw from his last game he ran into some
serious troubles let's see if he can
turn it around today get that win and
maybe have a chance at catching up if
you're just joining us for the first
time let's talk about the format we're
looking at to ten player round-robin
fields the time control is game in 90
minutes for the first 40 moves and then
there are 30 minutes added on for the
remainder of the game there is a 30
second increment from the very first
move and the players cannot agree to
drawers before blacks thirtieth move has
been played and also there is a
potential for playoffs and this could
get kind of tricky but I can mention to
mention it to you now since this is
quite possible if two players tie in a
field they're going to be playing a best
of two game in ten with a two second
delay and if one person gets one and a
half points it's over but if it's tied
one to one then they play a blitz
Armageddon 5 minute versus 4 minute game
where black has four minutes but the
trade-off is black has draw odds that's
right and so if black manages to just
draw that game he'll be crowned champion
of the 2019 spring chess classic yeah
and I guess 5 versus 4 is is the tipping
point that's where the Jazz scientists
have said that that's generally what's
been agreed upon but you know I think a
lot of players actually favor the black
pieces there might be speaking out of
turn but I know I definitely would
rather have the draws than 5 full
minutes yeah take a poll I guess we
ascent on both sides that's what we know
the balance is there have been three
playoffs in the history of the seasonal
classics before but it's never happened
between three or four players and that's
possible in Group A three or four
players they will contest a rapid
round-robin that's game intent with a
two-second delay and this this
terminology this wording is very
important it's not a knockout from that
round-robin if one player does not
emerge as the clear Victor then they
play a blitz round-robin
and if a clear Victor from that then
they play a series of Armageddon games
that would be interesting to see yeah I
have to ask Tony rich what is the format
for a series of Armageddon games that
seems kind of messy but hey hopefully we
don't get there if we do it might be
quite exciting to figure it out all
along the late all along the way we
would like to invite you to join us in
the YouTube chat and check out us chests
champs calm if you're not already there
that is where you can see the digital
boards and follow along with the entire
event okay Caleb it's time let's look at
the hearings for Group A what's
happening you might have going on okay
so Ariane tari versus roost M chasm
jonov Eric Hansen vs. Benjamin Bach Liam
Lee vs. Vasilyev on Chuck
varoujan Akopian vs. Ilya News Nick and
Jeffrey Zhang vs. ray Robson now three
of these games are extremely important
the three games at the bottom are going
to determine who will be the champion or
at least make it to a playoff situation
as far as I'm sorry sorry vs Kozma Shana
is not at the bottom that is our first
key matchup that we're looking at
because of re Atari who is within
shooting distance of a first place score
here yeah and going undefeated this
tournament actually only saying you know
one win in the first round but no one
has been able to take a full point off
of him yet first time matchup for these
two and up next is varoujan Akopian vs.
alien is nick and they've played one
time before but it wasn't in person it
was on in the protest league 2017 and
that game was a draw alien is Nick it's
his time cope ian is not within range of
first place but ninja Tech is going to
have to perform and at least get a draw
against Akopian in this one and then
finally Jeffrey Zhong versus Ray Robson
both of these players in the lead 5
points and neither has been Jeffrey has
not been defeated race did suffer a
defeat in the second round and these
players are no strangers to each
there ray has a lifetime one game lead
over Jeffrey and they've had three draws
the before it's spiced and of course the
US Championship yeah as to you know the
very very strong you know younger
players in the United States right now
they definitely are going to be seeing a
lot of each other for the years to come
in the fields yeah
let's glance at this game and see what
the progress is like absolutely so what
we've got going on here seems to have
originated from let's just go back to
the beginning see how we got here so it
came out of one night of 3d 5d for
Knight of 6 c4 c6 and then Geoffrey
actually decided to go for an exchange
Slav but and I'm not sure how familiar
are but the exchanged love but it has
quite a reputation right okay it kind of
has a reputation for not being the most
interesting games but you know the way
Geoffrey an array of handle buzz has
actually turned out you know to be
fairly interesting and I think there
have actually already been some chances
missed by both sides so white just
continues development naturally with
Knight to c3 Knight to c6 Bishop f4 and
now this move a six
rook to c1 and Bishop f5 and this was
partially a reason for a6 is it
indirectly helps defend this B pond then
and we're actually talking about this
yesterday with with them on but the
reason it indirectly defends the spawn
has actually seen a bit later we see III
a6 Queen b3 and now the point of a6 is a
little bit more clear you know black
wanted to to develop this bishop but he
wanted to make sure he had a you know
some defense for this be pond left
behind and you might be thinking well a
six doesn't defend b7 but after Knight
h5 this pawn is actually not capturable
well actually here it would be capture
ball for a moment because trap the Queen
what would happen on Queen d7 so yeah 95
is you know the classic idea but while
white still has this Bishop arounds you
know white can escape with Queen c7 for
the moment but so you know Geoffrey
probably didn't like the look of Knight
takes off for giving away his drawing
Bishop even though he does NAB this B
pond
so instead of that he just decided to
retreat his bishop with a will advance
the bishop with Bishop e5 then after he
f6 he retreated back to g3 and now after
93 h6 g3 White's going to have some
pressure along this open file but of
course you know black has grabbed the
Bishop Park which you know GM's are very
fond of you know and it's quite a strong
thing to give up so hopefully you know
Geoffrey is going to try to make use of
this h-file to put some pressure on
black and now after Bishop g6 now this
pawn definitely isn't capturable because
95 would in fact completely trapped the
Queen nowhere to go along the rank
nowhere to go along the file nowhere to
go diagonally that's just a pretty queen
done yeah so of course you know Geoffrey
he's no slouch she plays Knight h4 kind
of chasing this Bishop arounds black
plays Bishop to f7 now white plays this
move Bishop to d3 and this move actually
gives black quite a lot of problems you
know what would be the most natural move
for you to play here Ben what do you
what do you think comes naturally as
black as black I want to attack the
knight on the rim yeah so you might want
to attack this Knight
you might also want to develop this
bishop right you want to get your pieces
out so you might want to play something
like I don't know Bishop to e7 or Bishop
to d6 right maybe Bishop e7 eyeing up
you know this Knight in the future but
not why it actually has a very
interesting move in Knight to g6 and now
we really see the point of the circle on
this open H file coming into play this
pawn is actually pinched so there's no
way to capture this Knight and if you
were to move this circle away of course
you know h7 would fall and this would be
very good for white but the thing is you
know black really wouldn't have any
choice here because if you capture this
you can actually just recapture back
after King f8 once again in this pawn is
hanging maybe you want to capture with
the bishop maybe with the rook but you
know either way that's just a free pawn
for white so there's actually some
significant problems the black has to
deal with already and because of this
pressure coming from Knight to g6 or
Bishop to d6 black actually felt the
need to play f5 here
which instead of Bishop e7 he felt the
need to play f5 which really isn't a
move you want to play as black partially
because of the reason you know because
of the move that Jeffery actually played
in the game which is simply g4
you know black tried to close this
diagonal to prevent Knight g6 so White's
simply going to get rid of his doubled
pawn and try to open that diagonal again
in the process and after some thinking
array actually played g6 here simply
defending this pawn again but after G
takes f-5e takes f5 Jeffery actually had
a really good move that he missed here
and it actually comes you know through
the means of a tactical shot later on so
you know white played G for once trying
to open the diagonal like manage to keep
it closed by defending with his Jeep on
here but he simply could have tried to
open the diagonal once again with
another g4 push and of course you know
the the easy line to calculate is what
happens if you know black tries to take
and when simply we can now take the pawn
on g6 and once again you know h7 will
fall g6 has already fallen this would be
horrible for black he can try to you
know defend his pawn but there's simply
not enough defenders right we can just
go ahead and break through and capture
here so that would be another way to win
a pawn for white so black would have to
try to defend this pawn through tactical
means so you have any ideas here Ben for
what black might try to defend the yeah
so the fun the F pawn more specifically
is gonna kind of remove an attacker kind
of the opposite of a remove the defender
tactic
about night before a night before is
actually a key move and a lot of a lot
of these positions it's also part of the
reason why taking on b7 wasn't always
great because you know sometimes the
night before move comes in gaining time
on the bishop you know giving you time
to attack this Queen again here the the
bishop could just retreat and you know
the night might be loosely placed the
move I was thinking of was actually
Bishop to e7 hitting this night you know
not giving this night time to attack f5
and so Jeffery probably thought okay so
Bishop e7 I would have to move my knight
away and then none of the tactics work
there's actually the insane-looking
G takes f five here and after Bishop
takes a h4 Geoffrey can actually sack a
full rook here by taking on h4 and after
Queen takes h4 now the point is clear
after Queen to b7 and so just be a fork
of blacks pieces if you play something
like rook to d8 or work to be it I'm
simply going to take on c6 maybe King f8
and now play f6 and at the end of the
day black isn't exchanged up but if we
count the pawns it looks like white has
two pawns for it and blacks pieces are
completely discord innate 'add you know
none of black's pieces are working
together this King is locking this Rick
out of this game this Queen is kind of a
no man's land on h4 it could give a
check but you know simply king to d2 and
why does nothing to fear and this would
have been just completely crushing for
white this would have been close to game
over if they had continued down this
line but you know that would have
required Jeffery to see you know this
crazy-looking gf5 with the idea of
stacking this work on h4
and in the game Jeffrey didn't see this
and he just decided I'm gonna move my
knight away you know anticipating Bishop
e7 perhaps and this actually just goes
black a chance to kind of escape with
Bishop d6 and once again here he
actually could have taken advantage of
this week b7 poem by playing this move
Knight to g5 again you know all of
whites play is centered around you know
making use of this open H file that's
what he gave up the bishop there the
bishop pair for and so he
to make use of it in my opinion and if
of course the Queen takes we fall into
this same line with you no Queen takes
b7 so this also would have been awkward
for black but instead Geoffrey just
decided to Castle so kind of giving up
all of this pressure on the h-file by
removing the rook it does get his King
to a safer Square but it kind of lets
black off with you know castles King
side himself and now it's tough to find
you know any sort of advantage for white
in my opinion black does have the two
bishops
and yes this bishop is not looking great
for the moment but you know maybe one
day black will play f4 kind of break
down White's central pawns here and open
up a diagonal as well as you know his
rook and so it's not gonna be so easy
for Geoffrey to prove anything in this
game definitely some mischance is there
already
so this is the current position yeah let
me just update my board no it looks like
some more moves have been played
so after castles castles we saw 90 to 95
you know attacking the Queen the Queen
retreated back to d1 you wouldn't want
to put his queen on this open file
probably just where it would get kicked
around more no Queen f6 is played and
actually Queen back to a4 now that this
Queen has left the da square and this is
kind of sending off some alarm bells I
hope we don't see a repetition of moose
already it was something like Queen back
to d8 and Queen back to d1 well these
players might be fairly comfortable
taking a repetition in this game they
might be yeah but you know they're gonna
have to be careful cuz I'm I'm sure Ilya
is going to try to fight for more if he
sees that he has a chance to you walk
away with clear first and I wonder how
much that these players have gotten up
from the board and they're just I'm sure
they're quite often going to the other
games and just yeah survey in the
situation definitely looking around but
the other big factor here is actually
that the clocks you know these players
are only unmoved 21 and they have to get
to move 40 before they had extra time
and you know right down to 14 minutes
for those 19 moves and Geoffrey also
down below 20 minutes for these you know
next the next half of the first 40 moves
okay well let's stop by Group B and C
the pairings over in our challengers
division now two players can still
finish in first we know that but the
game is going on or Nikolas theodoro vs
hidan Stein Grimson Alexei Sorokin
versus Sergei Arenberg Alexander my
stove vs. Gregory kabe-don of Denis CAD
rich versus Andre bars bullets and
christine korilla vs bhaijan sheet and
now we know those two last games indeed
are the ones to look at Denis Kendrick
vs. Andre of Irish poets
Irish poets trying to get that full
point trying to get up there and join by
but it's not gonna be easy because all
by has to do in his game against korilla
is score just score anything against AZ
with black it's tough to touch that +4
score you know it's gonna be really
difficult yeah top seed by let's take a
look at his game with black against
Camilla
absolutely so it's actually been a day
for the exchanged loves this is our
current position
you know white has some pressure along
the G file but you know black cuz it's
going to have some nice outposts first
night and if you can get this piece is
coordinated it's going to be good for
him I feel let's take a look at how we
got here like I said it's a day for the
exchange Slav this time we reached it
directly without you know developing the
Knights C takes d5 C takes d5 Bishop f4
Knight to c6 you know we see this move
III so something we often tell beginners
in in the opening is you want to develop
your nights before your bishops usually
right great Christian is kind of you
know foregone this this statement
especially with this move III rather
than getting a night out but there's
actually a pretty interesting line the
black has if white isn't careful maybe
the natural-looking
Knight c3 can already run into some ePHI
of pawn sacrifices and black would have
some really interesting ideas after
those so e3 is definitely the move here
because you know in this e5 sacrifice
line a very common idea is to push this
pawn through to D
for kind of misplacing whites night and
it's already you know getting some
pressure so we see III instead and this
kind of you know puts a damper on blacks
ki5 ideas by controlling this d4 square
a little more closely so we do see III
Knight f6 Knight c3 Bishop f5 you know
black developing this Bishop early this
time without including a 6 we see Queen
to b3 oh well you have a result here
Sorokin and Arenberg has ended and feed
a master Alexei Sorokin has the victory
okay his final game you know
Sorokin had the norm possibilities he
was going for his third grandmaster norm
Wow
oh pardon me pardon me I was
misunderstood
Sergei Ehrenberg has the victory over
Sorokin but Sorokin the last the last
seed in this field
bee was looking for his Grandmaster in
his final Grandmaster norm that did not
play out for him unfortunately but it
was nice meeting him yeah do you want to
take a quick look at how that game ended
yeah let's go one way okay looking at
this final position here it seems as
though the white king is simply a little
bit too unsafe and white does have this
you know advanced pawn in h7 maybe with
some ideas on a the black King but
clearly it wasn't enough and after white
gets out of this check I'm not even sure
you know maybe there's some checkmating
ideas but simply you know black can take
this rook and then continue on
checkmating white up a full piece but
how did we get here
so it looks like this Bishop e5 move and
after Queen to c2 we saw Bishop takes b2
rook takes here and oh it looks like
it's simply a blunder yeah the space
should be five moves seems to just win
the game because after Queen c2 Bishop
takes B - you can't recapture this
Bishop because this leaves York hanging
but which is why you know white went for
rook takes d8 but now instead of simply
recapturing this rook allowing white to
recapture here black can throw in this
check
t4 which is an incredibly awkward for
white
you know the desperado might have
continued with rook takes d4
but unfortunately for white his king and
rook are placed slightly awkwardly and
of course the wreck would fall in this
line so no way to save the piece for
white kind of unfortunate for Alexei but
uh you know a well spotted tactic by
Sergei Arenberg a nice in-between move
yes an intermezzo sorts yeah that tactic
has like what like three or four
different names yeah the mission Zhuge
is well I don't know of any others to my
minds but so we can make more up yeah
yeah dipsy-doodle
all right do you want to pop back over
to the by chance you game yeah let's do
that for a moment yeah and then we'll
look at our prize funds all right so
yeah we saw the exchange Slough I think
we ended off around here both players
just developing their pieces though h3
rook c8 Knight f3 B five black expands
early on on the Queen side whereas you
know white might have had awkwardly
places Queen on c2 kind of opposing this
rook which is not ideal so a3 preventing
this move B 4 which would a you know
attack this pinch piece we see castles
castles a 695 h6 queenie to getting this
Queen off of this open file Queen to b6
connecting the rooks in g4 so weights
ideas are gonna come from the Kings side
he decides he wants to expand over here
get a little bit more space maybe launch
an attack on the black King even well
you know black is busy expanding over
here on the Queen side so we see Bishop
e8 defending some of these weak light
squares that were created by the move h6
g5 and H takes g5 Bishop takes g5 now
the G file is open we see Queen to d8
King h1 Knight to d7 black trading off
some of these attacking looking pieces
Knight 67 Queen d7 and rich g1 and now
this move f5 which is often a critical
move for for black when he's being
attacked in structures like these it
closes off this powerful bishop
it opens up his bishop that was you know
well-placed to defend these light
squares and you know even gives the
Turks in space if it needs to come up or
if he needs to defend the Jeep on along
the seventh ranked white continued with
32 g3 preparing to double black decided
that this was the right moment to take
off this extra attacking piece and after
work to c7 again putting more defenders
on the Sheep on as well as preparing to
stack up Brooks on this file later on we
saw her to g1 and Queen to d6 so I
continued with Queen f3 black of course
placed his night on this powerful
outpost attacking you know black White's
weak bonds white shuffles over even more
pieces to the Kings side leaving this
beep on in the dust and you know
Christian seemingly doesn't care he just
keeps bringing his pieces over to attack
and the black king so Stefan I'm gonna
be an interesting one here black has
definitely broken through on this Queen
side but if white can manage to a you
know generate a devastating attack black
is gonna be in some trouble so
definitely you know all three results
possible here although some I'm to my
eyes I don't really see this attack
working out for for white at first
glance it seems as though black is kind
of getting away with taking this pawn
for free his pieces are well placed to
help defend his king and so unless what
I can prove something pretty immediately
it's it's gonna be tough
alright so let's take a look at what
these players are fighting for we're
gonna see the prizes doled out today
here are the prize funds first the grand
prize for group a $6,000 and for Group B
it's $4,000 with a total combined prize
fund of 36 K not too shabby now in Group
A I do know that we have REM tari
fighting for just um play off these
cannot win outright absolutely and it
looks like Kasim jonov might have a shot
here against him so let's take a look at
that tank alright so what do we have
going on here looks like an end game
where white is simply up upon but you
know at the expense of this king
he's made some weaknesses definitely
around this King he has no pawns on the
second rank to help defend himself he's
pushed f4 and age 4 which of course
weakens this diagonal as well as the
second rank so you know Roose Tom's
gonna have to take advantage of this
weak King if he wants to stay in this
game otherwise you know this pawn on d5
is simply going to be very very
threatening okay look pardon me just one
moment we need to go to a co peon and
Nick Nick if we can that game has just
been drawn ah
and so niche Nick has that magical five
and a half points and if either Zhang or
Robson can emerge from their game
victorious then that player will be the
champion now we do know about yes so
definitely those players will have taken
note of this and they'll realize that
all they need is a draw to secure their
place in a playoff so that reality is
coming closer and closer to the truth
Bend we might see that three-way
round-robin or even four way if our
antartican can manage the thing in his
game
let's see really quickly how we achieved
this draw looks like you know after
Queen takes before Queen takes d6
material is even and then uh what black
continued with Rick to d8 and we saw
Queen e7 and Riki eight and a simple
repetition of moves really quickly if it
white you know captured what appears to
be this free night it looks as though
black would have this rook takes a four
move so material would stay balanced
besides you know maybe this extra pawn
for for white although it seems as
though blacks going to have some
pressure here and while white is
untangling his pieces for example this
knight black might get his rook involved
in the game and this pawn would like me
fall so this is probably why var decided
just to repeat the moves with Queen to
e7 and we saw this repetition ending in
a draw so a good result for Ilya it
feels
you know that five and a half not
guaranteeing him a spot in the playoffs
but you know just psychologically if
you're Ray Robson and Jeffries young and
you know that you know this draw gets me
a chance to fight for the title you've
it's got to be tempting to just go for
that drug you know let the opponent off
the hook maybe risk nothing get your
shot and in that rapid playoff at the
same time you got to imagine that Elia
had he's fairly confident that Robson
Shawn game is gonna be a draw as well
absolutely
okay let's go back to Terry in costume
genre if you don't mind sure that's
where we weren't right before we saw
that the that game had ended in a draw
yes so White's King is definitely weak
here and you were saying there might be
some tactical shot for furry stone
ribbon I saw I have not looked at the
line yet but I saw that the vigor was
like minus seven I reduced them so it's
Rick Fe a it was played so this queen is
going to have to move somewhere and it
looks as though part of the awkwardness
is coming from this Queen b6 idea so if
you imagine the White Queen moving off
of this diagonal this would simply be a
fork of whites king and rook and so it's
gonna have to kind of baby set this
diagonal for awhile and maybe simply and
that's just not doable because if you
play something like Queen f2 or
something like Queen c5 it looks as
though black can just continue with this
rookie to move and whites King is really
you know kind of hurting here I don't
see a great way to try and even prevent
this mate you are able to play rook to
f2 but it looks like black has a number
of options here not the least of which
is simply work to e8 preparing to take
on f2 and play the other rook into e2
and black controls this diagonal so
there are no perpetual opportunities or
checkmate opportunities well actually
okay maybe there are checkmate
opportunity open behind and Janna side I
was going to say you know there's no way
to attack this King on this diagonal
well now that would be mate though but
it was is there a skewer looming there
from from that combination yes so white
would be winning here because after King
g7
we can simply play this Oh take this
Queen and I'm not sure this is
completely winning but this extra pawn
would be pretty tough for black to deal
with even though you know White's King
still has some difficulties probably a
draw what would happen if if this were
to be played although it looks as though
there might actually be some checkmating
plans from white regardless you know
black doesn't have to allow any of this
we simply need to find a better move
after rook F to here which is not the
easiest task but I think where we're up
to it simply Queen to be one is
interesting but it's probably not enough
let's take another look here so Queen c5
is as the move I'm predicting from white
maybe something else might be played but
this one makes the most sense to me like
I said you do have to be careful of
losing this truck something else but I
can try is simply attacking this Queen
again perhaps forcing the Queen to an
even more awkward Square again you still
have to babysit this rook you can also
go to someplace like d5 but that allows
Queen d4 check as well and already you
know you can just see just by if I don't
hang any rooks you can already see
that's a you know blacks pieces are
surrounding this King and it's gonna be
definitely definitely be a hunt and
we'll just have to see if your stump can
find the most accurate continuation to
really put away this game looks like
Ariane is still considering his options
here just to see what he wants to do
with this Queen he's likely calculating
some of these same lines and seeing uh
maybe they don't turn out so well for me
I would like to go over to Group B and
look at our second key matchup Denis CAD
rich versus Andre bearish pullets marsh
bullets fighting to get into a playoff
situation well yes so uh at first glance
obviously white has this rook in
exchange for that black knight sitting
on g5 and it looks like white it's going
to be in
for a pleasant very pleasant endgame
well and especially look at the time
here but Andrea is down to less than a
minute and he has ten more moves to go
before time contralto in to my eyes this
is just completely winning forever wait
I don't see how black can hope to hold
this end game you can fracture White's
pawns with a move like Knight f3 but
after her to d5 well after it okay let's
say Bishop here and Richard e5 this one
game is gonna be very very difficult for
black to hold partially because of the
strong pawn on f5 kind of putting a you
know a damper on this F g7 f6 complex
but mainly because these pawns on the
Queen site are going to be very
difficult to defend and after move like
grip to d7 I think one of them is
already falling there's simply no way to
keep these pawns under control
but I can try and you know maybe launch
this H pawn but it's actually quite easy
for white to come around and make sure
there's no funny business and now with
the ability to create a passed pawn this
endgame should just be completely
winning in my opinion looks like he's
going for that H pawn a little bit early
on he went down to d8 and check the King
yes that's certainly another way to go
about this endgame so let me just update
this board here so we did see that line
I was mentioning with Knight takes f3
and Bishop e5 and he goes after the H
pun directly just ensuring that you know
this is the safe pawn doesn't doesn't
get anywhere and this is another fine
way to go about the son game is simply
activating your King next and just the
rook is just better than the bishop
that's just a fact of chess and it
should be a fairly trivial win I think
for white in the Sun game and if if CAD
rich wins then we know immediately yeah
Jannetty by will be the champion that's
it that's it for this B group it will be
decided then all we have to do then is
just wait for by to finish his game and
then interview him so
and Weavin actually we've had guests on
the show before who will lose their last
game still come down for the victory
interview though hey Robin you know I'm
the champ yes certainly certainly you
know feeling good regardless of the last
round result so I failed to mention I
think early on that Eric Hanson and
Benjamin Bach had drawn their game in
Group A but also there is another game
in Group A that dews that does not have
first place first place implications
yeah but Liam Lee versus Vasilyev on
Chuck is certainly worth looking at yeah
this seems as though it's another crazy
position we've seen a lot of these games
in this tournament where the black king
is simply stuck in the center because he
has no shelter in the Kings side and no
shelter on the Queen side it's a very
strange-looking kind of fortress black
it's made to is that a stable fortress
right there Kim I'm gonna say it's it's
pretty unstable up and you know this
Knight is holding on to this rook this
King is kind of holding everything
together himself and these rooks are
barely holding on to these these pawns
in this Knight a move like ninety six
looks almost completely winning but if
fortunately this clean is holding on to
this pawn and like I said this Knight
has this rook and everything is just
barely you know barely holding on here
we saw the move rook F two from white
and Queen C six from black and it's
almost like black doesn't want to touch
his pieces because like I said
everything is just so shakily holding
together that you know one one wrong
movement it's all over for black that
being said I don't see immediately how
to break through for white which is
probably why we saw this move work F to
simply defending this beep on one thing
I can do is probably play something like
g4 here you know preventing black from
ever pushing this pawn not that he'd
especially want to but you know putting
an even greater hold on blacks position
you know something like pawns g5 really
eyeing this this week dark square here
it's gonna be problematic for black for
sure
could we pry the black King out of the
fortress by
playing something it starts with like
tonight at 5:00 yeah not a five looks
like another reasonable move with the
idea of playing you know Knight and g7
and then attacking this this King again
and off the bat I don't immediately see
how blacks intending to deal with this
especially with the other option 96
coming what let's try something like you
know you know if I honestly couldn't
tell you this looks a stress right yeah
yeah yeah but it looks like Lee just
actually pulled his erock back wow
that's actually very interesting
like like I said it is you're gonna
stack it on f4 is that that looks like a
possibility here but another thing is
black simply can't move right like you
can't move any of these pieces right now
maybe this rook can go somewhere but
that's not really gonna help his
situation with the King
something like Queen g5 still keeps that
King cut off and there's really nowhere
to go so I think laQuan liam is simply
taking his time here not rushing things
but uh yeah right off the bat this is
the snide f5 move what's extremely
dangerous I'm interested in in what
defense Black was planning if you were
to see something like this in the game
let's see how we got here really quickly
because that is a very strange position
so it came from another Slav or well
kind of a Slav structure white opted to
fianchetto though white chased this
Bishop around a little bit and then we
saw this move f4 so you know a common
idea in these games is playing this f4
and white expanding on this Kings side
which it seems to have worked out for
him well in this game black played a
very interesting pawn sacrifice here
opening up the Kings side for his rook
but giving up a pawn in the process
turgor g8 we saw Bishop f4 and just
going through the moves here it looks as
though you know black never intended to
Castle he was just planning on leaving
his King here for the whole game but
after this pawn on d5 Falls
like that you know it's it's really
tough for black because this d5 move is
coming like you said this not a five
move might be coming pressure on f7 is
coming you know there's simply too many
things for black to try to hold on to I
really do think you know White has a
sizable lead in this game but at the
same time a van Schaik is not going to
resign immediately probably he's gonna
move course not and we proved it yeah
and we actually see some more moves
being played so yeah we saw Knight to b6
from black but like I said that you know
black didn't really want to touch any of
these pieces because now this allows the
snake g6 idea because the knight is no
longer defending this rook on f8 so now
we see this pin coming into play black
was quick to respond though with nice to
d5 but simply Queen f3 maintaining this
pin and I really don't know what black
intends to do about this f7 pawn I said
you can't move this wreck away because
they've been that's checkmate right what
do you do
rook d7 now yeah I mean riff d7 but it's
giving up the exchange simply and you
know blacks actually already down upon
in this position so these end games are
not gonna be favorable yeah I unless he
finds some way to tactically you know
save his rook here I think this is close
to game close to game well we certainly
have had a good time watching Liam Lee
in this event and while he finishes in
the middle of the pack we hope to see
him back after this tournament very very
interesting chess this round yes indeed
okay and in what let's let's check in
with Jean Robson which is like the key
matchup of key matchup absolutely yes
this is the one that counts looks like
quite a bit of progress has actually
been made since we last checked in here
so we saw of course this position white
began Rima nuvaring his pieces
and instead of Queen to d8 of course we
saw Knight to c4 putting this knight on
the strong outpost a very common idea in
these structures and an idea we've
actually seen a lot of today is in these
exchange Slav structures this c4 square
becomes a very nice square for this name
you know attacking these kind of weak
pawns sitting on the starting starting
squares for white so white just defends
these pawns the knight drops back to a5
you know it seems the slow array is
eyeing a couple of repetitions here but
Jeffrey you know Amon has been talking
about it a lot you know he loves to play
chess so definitely not going to see too
many early repetitions out of him which
is why he went for this very interesting
idea of Knight e5 actually a pawn
sacrifice and now because of the
sacrifice is actually able to get his
Queen into the c7 square he's able to
infiltrate now that this dark square
Bishop is gone for black we saw Queen
take c7 and Rick takes c7 and now after
rook c8 orc c1 it seems as though white
is going to have the more active rook in
this endgame despite being down upon and
then from Rey we saw the very
interesting move d4 so earlier on we
were talking about you know this Bishop
might be a problem piece but hopefully
black can find a way to extract it and
this is just what Ray he's doing here
he's extracting this bishop he's giving
up this pawn on d4 maybe after something
like 94 but he's probably gaining it
back right away on the a2 squared so is
it worth pushing the a pawn instead to
a3 or something uh well that's not
something you really have time to do
right because simply F takes III and
after F takes c3 these pawns are gonna
be shattered for this endgame it
definitely too many weaknesses for right
here with that being said it's kind of
tough to find the move for Geoffrey here
perhaps we're going to see some
liquidation of material after something
like b3 here making a lot of threats
including something like ninety six and
Bishop c4 you actually can't take this
pawn with a night due to this Bishop c4
check so we might see Bishop takes b3
and then after Knight takes b3
well this is interesting it actually
seems as though you know you still get
the fork anyways so maybe this opponenet
to actually can't be captured after
Knight takes d4 okay let me just update
the position it's always like in trouble
now because of this well yeah we can
just take the knight on thee
yeah we actually see you know Geoffrey
thinking here so maybe he's found this
line and he's trying to go over you know
what he might be missing I wouldn't go
as far as to say blacks in serious
trouble because you know white did
sacrifice this pawn earlier so black
isn't done material just yet but so this
is definitely sidelines and if you're
not able to take this pawn and get this
be three square I think there's serious
problems for it for black here and
reorganizing his pieces we might see
something like Bishop to d5 out of black
here kind of trying to like I said
reposition his pieces but it's kind of
unclear to me if it's going to be enough
or if you know this weakens
seventh-ranked this is a common theme
you know today is this F pawn moves and
the seventh rank becomes a lot weaker in
every endgame
so we'll be interesting to see if you
know ray can find a way to maneuver out
of this or if you know this a pawn
actually is uncapturable it's my eyes
that I really don't see a way for I'd
like to get away with taking this unless
he's simply planning to leave his Bishop
here but I'm not sure he can you know
stop rook c2 if that is the the route he
goes for maybe Rick d8 here and then uh
and this might be the complication that
Jeffries is still thinking about because
if rook c2 there's always this bishop be
one move so you can trap this Bishop but
maybe it's not so easy to capture it we
have a result in Group B Nicholas
theodoro has fallen at the hands of he
Evans Stein grooms in Wow
the Icelandic Grandmaster is taking
another another victim in these final
rounds yes he had kind of a slow start
to this tournament but he's definitely
picking up pace now
with these two wins in the last two
rounds so let's uh can we go back and
look at the last few moves yeah
absolutely so it looks as though white
is down in astonishing three pawns
uh-huh but in exchange he is up in
exchange and maybe has an attack on the
black King
so this Bishop is taboo because of Rick
d8 check leading directly into mate
after rook f8 or it takes that fate mark
queen takes up it so instead we saw
Bishop g7 protecting this eighth rank
after Queen f4 you know defending this
Bishop we saw Bishop c6 so like is
saying I have three pawns for the
exchange that's more than enough I'm
just gonna trade off some pieces here
and you know get to the send game and
then instead of allowing that white
actually goes for another sacrifice in
place Bishop takes g6 you know maybe you
know this Bishop isn't capturable due to
H takes you six and Queen takes b4 which
is why we saw Queen takes f4 but now
after King Bishop f7 King f7 Bishop at
four the material account actually is no
even pieces and black is up to pawns
which makes me think I miscounted
originally and you know why it wasn't
actually up in exchange let's take
another look you know counting is very
difficult so let's see yeah white is
actually down in exchange as well as
three pawns here which is kind of insane
which is why you know after this trade
of pieces happened
we saw her g8 and pretty quickly
white threw in the towel being down a
let's see now four pawns with no
compensation
so Stein grim is in yeah as you said
when's his last two wasn't his best
tournament very nice guy though yeah no
it's definitely a a good guy okay Group
B Alexander me stuff versus Gregory tied
Donna let's take a look at this game
let's see what's going on looks like
we've got a minor piece and game where
white is up a full pawn
but his night is slightly awkward for
the moment so yeah definitely why it's
the gonna be the one pressing here but
he does have to be very careful because
you know that that Bishop can kind of
get nasty especially with these pawns
locked on dark squares on a g3 and h4 so
let's see it's actually black to move
here so to my eyes I'm wondering about
this move Bishop e5 already just you
know going directly after this pawn it
does look this Knight out of its cage
but after something like you know King
e6 already I guess you know we would see
g4 coming and maybe there's there's a
bishop g3 here but you know it's it's
kind of tough to defend all these dark
spread pawns for white but it looks like
he's he's barely holding on here was
something like meta 5 and yeah this this
would be disastrous for black so
attacking this pawn right away isn't
gonna work for black so it's kind of
tough to find a move maybe we'll see
something like g5 it's a very common
idea and then games where you're trying
to draw to trade off pawns just so you
get closer and closer to that you know
draw an endgame where there's nothing
left on the board so you know there's no
possibility for promotion so we see this
g5 move maybe and white might continue
like this and bring his King into the
game and you know already we see you
know possibly black it would be able to
trade even more pumps off with something
like age 4 this is certainly how I would
go about treating this in game is just
taking off some of these you know pawns
kind of breaking up this formation for
white so that you know there's less
chances of getting the pawns rolling
together like you would see with the
move like g4 do you have a result in
Liam Lee has defeated Vasilyev on Chucky
Vaughn Chuck has resigned the house was
crumbling yeah certainly a you know that
King in the center of the board that
doesn't work well so let's quickly see
how that game actually did finish up so
we did see you remove rook d7 but you
know what like I mentioned this trick is
simply falling on a fate
after King takes off for Queen h5 Queen
b6 we suck when AJ check Queen d7 the
King tried to run away but it founds no
shelter on the Queen side either
returned to his home on e7 and after
rook f1 yeah black simply resigns
there's no way to really deal with all
these threats on the f7 pawn if you move
this came back for example to try to
defend laterally you'll simply run into
this check and the pawn will fall
anyways so he decided you know enough
was enough
it's time to throw in the towel alright
and as I look into the YouTube chat
you've got some fans Kayla some fans
yeah they said no way is this guy only
2000 and where can people check you out
online check me out on line well I
definitely have some interesting classes
and lectures out on the st. Louis Chess
Club YouTube you don't see it yeah so if
you guys are interested in getting to
the to the mm rating yourself be sure to
check out the road to mm online you know
weekly lectures every Wednesday night ly
live streams ya actually interact with
you guys and there as well it's a lot of
fun very cool okay so let us continue
with our Antares game against her some
Kasim Joe yeah things steel this is
turning out its some finds some accurate
moves he's finding some stuff yeah
alright yeah
rook rook to e8 and yes we last left off
at rook F to e 8 and then I was
predicting a move like Queen to c5 but
so he actually went with Queen a3
instead let's see if we can get the
board up on the screen yeah there we go
ah yes so Rick Fe a and then of course I
was mentioning you know the screen can't
go somewhere natural because of this
Queen b6 check you know picking up this
rook so instead we saw you know Queen to
a3 protecting this York still but you
know giving up on this diagonal kind of
it's it's gonna be dangerous and so
black of course does not want these
Queens off the board so you played Queen
to d2 and this is setting up some very
nasty threats earlier in my analysis we
looking at something like the rook
coming into e2 but maybe ruse Tom's idea
is to bring the rope behind the Queen
you know creating even more devastating
threats of checkmate immediately and
part of the reason why I was expecting a
move like Queen c5 was because it kept
an eye on this F 2 square so if we were
to see a move let's just pass for right
here I move like grip to be 2 with this
Queen on c5 we would be able to play
your f2 here trying to you know block
off the second rank but such a move
isn't really possible with this Queen
sitting here on a 3 so it'll be
interesting to see how you know white
wants to meet these ideas we might see
this Queen come back to c5 anyways we
might also see I'm not sure maybe
something like Queen f3 but so once
again I move like this is already going
to be really awkward after rook F 2 we
can actually maybe just there should be
some way to win a rook here I'm not
finding it but yeah maybe just check and
check and takes this rook and at this
point for Atari Queen f3 would be a
mistake obviously but maybe Queen c5
controlling this up to square okay
if those rooks came down though they
came down to the second rank is black
solid in that regard does he have to
look out for those back rank mates
yeah those same ideas so maybe
immediately he can't bring both wrecks
to the second rank right because and we
saw this mr. k-8 and this is this Queen
f8 idea but I wonder if it's if it
actually even leads to a mate or the
black king can escape somehow uh yeah
that'd be interesting to see but the the
thing is you know it's almost not even
necessary to bring down both rocks right
away because you know rook b2 is already
you know threatening enough right you
know you can't stop checkmate if it was
black to move here and rook b2 was
played there's no way to stop the mate
so white already has to deal with this
this first rook and then you know once
he brings one Rick down maybe the white
pieces are gonna be distracted and
they're not gonna be able to keep up
these threats on the f8 Square and the
a8 Square and they're gonna have to come
back and defend the King and that's when
we might see that that second row come
into play and also you know black can
start doing things with with check
pretty soon and that's when you know
what's really not gonna have a chance to
try and counter punch on this this King
on g8 with that in mind what is our
current position here
let's see alright so we do see Rick f2
so you know White's not giving black a
chance to double in the second he's
playing Rick up to immediately but now I
thought this left behind the first drink
yeah so we actually do see Rick b1 being
played and now something like queen
dee-1
and you've controlled the second-ranked
but you've left behind the first so
queen h1 is simply a track mating threat
and I really am not sure what white
intends to do about this perhaps even
Queen to d1 is slightly more accurate
controlling us f3 score but no we
actually do see Queen e1 in the game and
yeah looking looking at the players on
the board it looks like you know Bruce
Thomas is ready to call it here user
just give give matin and call it a day
yeah if tired of wisdom we'll call it
for him yeah so King f3 trying to run
away doesn't quite work we see some move
probably uh there's probably a queen
efore and then after you know a king up
to g4 let's try and find a mate here
it's not trivial look I'm sure it's
trivial for it for roost on but it's not
so trivial for me
it looks as though something like h5
King h3 rook h1 h2 and maybe we would
see a queen of five move and after a
king g2 we might see Brooke h2 king h2
and now of course the second rook would
come in with check and we would find
made on the back rank which that's kind
of a long line but actually a lot of
those moves are quite forcing and so did
we see a resignation actually happen oh
yeah alright so that will be that for
our atari so no chance at winning this
this spring classic anymore for him
right in roost in kazan of you know the
2004 feeder world champion and finishes
at -2 and but it's a his his game today
was strong enough to knock out re antara
who finishes with an even score or four
and a half out of
and I mean that that tells you something
about how close this term it is yes
lower score is just such an even even
field yeah no definitely it's it's a
very even competition with a lot of
incredibly strong players you know roost
um as you mentioned you know feed a
world champion in 2004 and sig knockout
so to see him going - to really shows
you how how strong this field is this
year and so yeah just to quickly mention
roost on went for Queen d1 which is a
lot simpler than the line so I was
talking about after king gu - we would
see Quidditch one mate and of course if
rookie to simply Queen takes and it's
checked man so matin - is is the problem
here for for white well now it comes
down to one game in Group A yeah that's
exactly right let's head up check back
in and see how how they're doing it
looks like we've got you know an even
even more simplified endgame white does
have this incredibly far advanced beep
on which is going to cause black some
trouble if he's not careful but black
has this ape on an exchange let's very
quickly see how the material did
liquidate so we saw Bishop takes a two
and instead of this b3 move which kind
of you know trapped the bishop but you
know there's no good way to attack it we
saw v4 forcing this night away and now
of course takes and takes and that's how
we achieve this even material end game
black played a5 but maybe this move was
this move seems forced because this pawn
is attacked twice but it actually does
give white this chance to play b5 and
kind of push through first so after a
four v6 we saw rook b8 played here on
the board and Bishop a six and this is
the current position which to my eyes
I'm slightly confused for black here
because I'm not seeing a great way to
prevent this pawn from advancing all the
way up the board of course you know the
threat if you simply bring the bishop
back I'm going to play York see a check
after takes and takes this pawn is going
home spawn is going home Ben
and there's no way to really stop it you
can try a three but due to the
unfortunate place placement of your
pieces you actually cannot Queen here
due to this fork in the end oh so yeah
you can play a - I can Queen I guess you
can actually clean with check oh my
goodness so this would be a pretty crazy
line here actually this might actually
be you know a relevant variation because
I don't see you know any kind of Forks
in the road for for white here I think
this is kind of the line he would have
to go down let's see so we saw Trixie
let's just try and calculate this again
rook c8 takes ticks a 3 B 7 and so a 2
is the move on I'm curious about here I
wonder if there's some Bishop e6 check
maybe King g7 yeah I'm not entirely sure
let's see what the players have done on
the board so we saw yes so in to prevent
rook c8 we saw King g7 from black but
now this allows this move B 7 and after
Bishop d5 let's see what Geoffrey has in
mind here once again there is this rook
c8 idea and I'm not sure what the what
the plan is for black I think he might
just be giving up an exchange I don't
think there's a way out here for Ray
like we sent them yet versus the pawns
that okay you've got a pawn I've got
upon both past but yeah the black just
doesn't look like he has a future here
yeah so to my eyes you know
looks like Geoffrey inserted a rook c5
even and now of course you can't take
this pawn due to this fork and if you
try to stay on this diagonal I can
simply push you away again and it seems
as though Geoffrey's getting everything
without giving up anything in this line
I really didn't see the immediate
refutation of this Bishop d5 move but it
feels so so there might be something
lurking there that that I just haven't
caught onto yet maybe here maybe this is
a problem
if you play a three I can play this
sport and this is quite an interesting
tactic actually now if you were to take
I can push this pawn and I would clean
with check and if you actually don't
take then I can of course take this
bishop and stop your pollen just in time
so that might be the the reason that
that Ray didn't go for this Bishop d5
move interesting Bishop e6 check right
away and it's important to remember that
the if there is a winner here and it
looks like there's gonna be one of my
feet you agree that's a walk-off homer
though they will win the entire term I I
don't see how Ray's gonna get out of
this one I think Geoffrey's simply
winning this endgame and that will that
will be it for the egg group in the
spring Classic we will have a champion
Illya initiatives gotta be by watching
this one yeah bring that hoping that
Jean messes up but it doesn't look like
he will and if Jeffrey wins he'll be the
first two times seasonal Classic
champion in the series history yeah a
repeat would that be a repeat winner and
did he win he actually won the last the
last spring classic so yeah the 2018
mm-hmm back-to-back champion yeah but no
records here so you all the champions
here of all the the seasonal classics
this is the the first the first seasonal
classic that has had three editions it's
the first third annual one there's one
beer so yeah well sometimes the winter
you know mixing around
it's not even spring right like who's
keeping track of these he actually saw
Bishop e6 from right here so he's trying
to hold on to this c8 square but it
seems the rook c8 is simply possible for
him from Jeffrey and then now if we
would just see a liquidation this pawn
is pretty far advanced but you know
white isn't time to stop it so I really
think you know why it's going going to
walk away with the victory here
something that Group B is kind of
setting up some flags here both baarish
pullets and buy in their respective
games are not doing well if they both
lose well then buy wins still use the
field
and buys game yeah the first korilla buy
yeah i christian uh having a lot of ups
and downs in this event right he's
played some very good games and he's had
some kind of Heartbreakers and he's had
some miracle saves we saw this rook
takes f7 you know miracle save it and
round seven I believe it was where we
had kind of written him off he was down
a full rook but he he somehow came back
but let's see what he's got going on
here and in this position so it looks as
though so I just captured the pawn on b4
those are those pawns have been traded
uh yes so white is actually up a pawn
here at first glance and perhaps even
more relevant than that is this King on
h8 it's out of the game
it's out of play and it's kind of being
attacked are you worried though about
the past pawn on before yes and no I'm
only worried it might distract me from
checkmating the black I'm not worried
about that that Paul never making it all
the way if need be white can simply play
Knight up for here this bishop has to
find a home and I can place my work
behind this pawn and it's going to be
tough to advance this guy with lift my
Europe behind the pawn you know as we
always say rooks go by and passed pawns
but so yeah I would also be tempted to
just try and ignore this opponent and go
for something immediate with king h4 and
you know king g5 and really just coming
after this King because if you were to
just try to push this pawn this is just
a forced to mate I believe you have to
come back to c8 and now let's let's see
if there's a knockout blow
anywhere here perhaps perhaps there
isn't but again Rick b7 and this phone
is going nowhere so definitely white
with all the chances you know he can
probably come around and pick up these
pawns at his leisure but I don't I don't
see by holding this actually I think
this is this is gonna be very very tough
very very tough see the position on the
board Christian is still thinking they
just hit that move forty a couple moves
ago so they do have that extra half-hour
now
so definitely the position to take his
time
and figure out what he wants to do how
he wants to handle this and the other
game in this field which we're looking
at average versus bearish pullets
right yeah it's look at that so you said
uh at bars bowling is uh be kind of
suffering here yet we do see he did go
down an exchange so let's quickly go
back in and see what happened oh yeah we
actually saw this position so we know he
was going down this exchange and looking
here yes simply you know this this this
Bishop is not gonna be able to hold
against this rook there are too many
weak pawns
you know b6 f6 and h6 are all gonna be
weaknesses that that white can attack as
well as this King so we might see
something like f5 get pushed you know
forcing this King onto some awkward
squares and then the stroke pushing this
King even further away and then we'll
see you know the end coming just for
example if we saw a move like h5 or even
let's just play a passing move for black
here we would see something like f5 and
now no matter where the King goes
there's gonna be an annoying check and
the king is gonna be forced to the side
of the board and already you see you
know black can't hold on to everything
if the King were to come the other way
we would see this other horizontal check
now and once again the Kings on the side
of the board I can bring my King around
and there's not gonna be any way for you
to hold on to this onion so I'm
predicting a loss from both of our
leaders than both by and Andre it is
happening before you know I said we've
had we've had the the champion here F on
the coming off of a loss but yeah that
looks like the Bosnian champion CAD Raj
has harsh bullets the number in this one
yeah so we actually did CH 5 and instead
of throwing in this f5 move white kept
that score open for his King and after a
move like king f7 we might see something
like rook h8 simply attacking this pawn
and then after king g6 I really do like
this stuff 5 move I think you should
play it but
he can do that at his leisure I guess
Kim Deniz Kade Rick big news in Group A
we've had material liquidated off the
board we need to go back to Jeffrey
Zhang and Ray Robson so yeah there's
actually not too much to analyze in this
in this endgame actually because white
does just have that extra piece its
Geoffrey's turn if he wants to keep this
King out completely you can play a
Bishop c4 here if the King were to come
to e4 the King can come to e2 and yeah
there's there's really no chance for
black here unless he manages somehow to
take all three of these pawns which is
gonna be you know kind of a kind of very
difficult obviously but yeah I'm
predicting we might see a king e4 if in
the case of Bishop c4 and then maybe an
f4 move here and trying to get rid of at
least one of these pawns could ray
Robson and then if a three maybe a
Bishop c4 check and the bishop can guard
this pawn as well as advance the spawn
of the board and once White has a passed
pawn like this it really is kind of just
over because you can waste time with
this Bishop and you know black really I
don't know
black black doesn't have a chance here
anyway by wasting time with the bishop
you mean you know the black pawns can
only move forward yeah you're just using
waiting moves right so yeah if for one
thing the bishop can control some key
squares can prevent the black King from
coming to kill some key squares but the
other thing is you know of course we
talked about the opposition and tres
let's see here so already you know the
black king is keeping the white king out
but what can pass and then black has to
play a move you can push up on forward
but then you know white can pass again
right and we see that you know while
white is doing nothing black is being
forced to push his pawns forward
although I'm not sure you know white
would want to allow these pawns to get
quite so far up the board so maybe we
would see something like g4 be played
from from the white point of view
I guess there are some complications to
be careful of because you know if black
does get a passed pawn on the other side
of the board
White's pieces might get tied down and
we might actually see a draw but I
really don't see Jeffrey blowing this
one I really think he he's got this
under control if you've been following
along at us chess champs calm you know
that if this game ends in a draw then
both Jeffrey and Ray will play a
three-way rapid round robin with iliyan
is Nick and and hopefully that will
decide our undisputed winner but yeah
winner takes all in this one and Jeffrey
for choice all right and then uh is this
the last game in the a group code that
is the last game in the a group we still
have three games going just ever our
three key matches right well yeah I mean
that we have we have some ones to watch
I don't know if anything has changed
though the last time we looked at our
and our B group games
yeah it looks as though uh you know
Dennis is making quite a bit of progress
here he just played f5 check this move
that I've been talking about and so this
really takes away too many squares from
this black King and we will see this
pawn drop pretty soon as well as this H
pun and like I said there's just far too
many weaknesses for black his pawns are
separated his bones can't defend each
other this opponent b6 is backward and
tying this Bishop down over here as well
as over here as well as on H on the H
file
you know bishops are pretty good but
they're not super pieces you know they
they can't go all over the board all at
once so I you know I think this one is
definitely in the bag this game I think
still has quite a bit left to go I think
you know if I definitely have some
chances to maybe not lose you know
directly some chances to make some
complications you know whenever there's
a passed pawn on the board you always
have to be careful right because those
things can get going they can get going
running pretty quickly but
yeah it's gonna be interesting to see
how Christian wants to deal with this
he's been thinking for quite a long time
now on let's move somewhere close to I
think like 15 minutes but maybe closer
to 10 but still it's it's tough to to
see what what he's really calculating
here like I said I think the simplest
move is just a night F for hitting this
Bishop preventing the search from from
checking and after this bishop moves
switch it really can only go back to D 1
maybe G 6 but I don't think that's the a
great idea tying down the rook and then
uh White has a couple options here one
of which is just attacking this pawn if
the pawn comes to b3 you can just take
another pawn for free and then this I
think would also be a very simple way to
kind of lock this game down this b-pawn
does survive though so like I said
there's always gonna be some
complications no matter how many puns
you're up it looks like gorilla is
approaching by with king h4 yeah this is
the other idea that I talked about right
so this idea of just bringing the king
in and checkmating black right it's also
a tough idea to stop you know this King
might also kind of fake black out you
know instead of going for checkmate he
might just come take these pawns
definitely a lot of choices for white
here a lot of ways to win and probably a
Christian was just deciding between them
alright with that in mind let's see
Jeffrey's still thinking in this
position so I guess he's decided there's
there's more complications than I was
saying which fair enough because in my
analysis you know I was I was kind of
talking a big game saying yeah there's
no way black and can hold this but I
managed to run myself innocent some
complications if you're paying attention
so let's see how would you approach the
send game
Bishop c4 then Bishop a - yeah Bishop c4
mission bay - is was my immediate
thought but you know this this King e4
idea followed by something like F 4
maybe even F 4 immediately seems like it
might be slightly problematic just
trading off some some ponds right away
it'd be nice if we could run our King
all the way over take this phone but I'm
not sure a bishop can kind of hold off
the black king alone while we go over
and waste a bunch of time doing that for
example King f1 here takes takes if
something like he need for maybe King e2
and already something like h5 of course
it'd be a mistake for black to play g5
and why do you think that has been
there's a really great move for white
here it's a mistake to play g5 it's a
very common idea in a pawn on games like
this Oh bishop skewer d3 yeah oh okay
so I didn't even see that there is the
skewer in the position though but let's
say you know a3
I play Bishop a - and now g5 there's
still a mistake here in the move g5 of
course now you'd like to skewer it but
uh you know unfortunately you've a lot
of black - Queen yeah common idea in
chess which doesn't get talked about a
whole lot it's kind of economy of pieces
right you know doing the most with your
pieces being efficient with them so
about g4 yeah g4 is a very efficient
move because all of a sudden blacks -
pawns are being prevented by your one
pawn right and this is simply just you
know a great advantage to have and now
of course you know something like black
would have to pass
and now this is where you know this
Bishop being able to waste time really
comes in handy because you know this
King is gonna have to move around
whereas I can always pass when I need to
enforce you to go back and so an endgame
like this would be completely winning
but
move like h5 would be a lot more tricky
preventing this pawn from stopping the
the kingside pawns from flowing and you
know this might run into some some
complications for Jeffrey here if he
allows these pawns and the King said to
get rolling we have a big announcement
to make
alright be Dennis CAD Raj has defeated
Andre bershka let's which means that the
group beat champion is by Jin Chi from
China and we will hopefully get to talk
together his game is finished I imagine
he is on the road to well maybe not a
place that he wants to be but still yeah
you got to be a happier walking away
with $4,000 that's that's true that has
quite a bit of money for for a week and
a half's work and yeah like but plus for
going into the last round it's really a
sizable lead and he's really earned at
this tournament this is the first game I
think we've actually seen him in any
kind of trouble at all he's really just
had you know quick you know simple games
like not simple but easy to follow and
the fact that you know he plays moves
that makes sense and he kind of just out
plays his opponents doing so and when
complications do it rise you know he's
he's never kind of shied away from them
right he's kind of taken them head-on
and definitely proven himself to be
better than his opponents when whenever
the situation arised or arose while we
are waiting for our remaining key
matchups to finish let's glance back at
the lone bean on key matchup right oh
there's a anti Donald
alright oh yeah this one so we did
actually see this this change in
structure that I was talking about with
this F pawn moving from F 3 to F 4 so
this isn't really something white wanted
to do he kind of had to do it to keep
this Bishop from coming after these
pawns yeah we see a so if we were to see
a you know a knight f1 here instead of
f4 I'm interested in what
what blacks plan actually was I'm not
sure why f4 had to be played because
it's really not a move you want to play
as white and the reason for that is with
this pawn in f3 you're able to play this
move g4 at some key moment and thus move
g4 gives you this past age pawn to work
with
whereas now after f4 has been played
this g4 move isn't really you know
available anymore and it's the same idea
if you know being efficient with the
pawns you know this black pawn is
stopping both of these white pawns in
their tracks and this pawn is stopping
this spawn so you know black is down
upon but you know the way he's using his
pawns is making it such that you know
white can't advance any of his in
addition to that you know blacks keying
is slightly more active it's got
slightly more essential control in this
Knight it's still looking you know quite
silly it's tough to see how White's
gonna try to untangle here and try to
win this game
let's see the current position it looks
like you know why just made some
progress getting this Knight out but
he's given up more squares with this
King so if he's not careful we might see
this King kind of come running of course
you know black doesn't want to leave the
Kings side completely unattended but you
know there are some dangers here if
white is completely careless with the
Queen side one winning idea you might
see is black white has placed his pawns
on dark squares which is the same color
as this Bishop which usually isn't ideal
but one advantage of it
is that it forces this pawn to be on a
light square right this h5 pawn so we
might see this Knight try and maneuver
itself somewhere where it can attack
this this h5 pond may be seeing at f5
and then a Knight to f4 you know really
taking advantage of the bishops
inability to defend this pawn with that
in mind it's it's gonna be interesting
to see how mister wants to handle this
position he's also got a 50-minute
advantage on the clock so you know black
definitely is gonna have to be moving
quickly and thinking on his opponent's
time here otherwise you know it's it's
gonna be very difficult not to have to
fall into some traps
anything new going on in our us
championship rivalry in Group A Zhang
and Robson to determine the overall
champion let's take another look here
looks like Geoffrey is still thinking
nothing move which nothing different you
really can't blame him you know from
what I've seen of Geoffrey's play he's
the type of player to you know get to
the critical moment in this case you
know the beginning of this piece up
endgame and he wants to work it all out
before he makes any decisions which is a
great way to go about this cuz you know
and onions that are this simple the
Lions aren't entirely too complex to
calculate you know it's very linear
you know black is gonna have this idea
of f4 and then he's gonna want to
probably try to push these pawns and
trade them off for these pawns right
he knows what blacks gonna do and so
he's just thinking out in his head
what's the best way for me to kind of
prevent these these ideas from coming to
fruition for black yeah and and so he's
he's just calculating it all out I would
imagine which is a great way to play
accurate chess
I'd like to remind you while we're
waiting for some moves to be made and in
this particular game the US Championship
does start in ten days oh yeah ten days
march March 20th is round one is it
March 20 the h19 the 18th is actually
the opening ceremony and then there's
like a community day and it's it's kind
of odd it's staggered back but then the
20th is round one and we're gonna be
seeing Geoffrey Zhang and Ray Robson in
that field of course the US Championship
has become the stronger national
championship in the entire world
we have Fabiano Carolina who just
challenged for the world championship by
the way the grand chest Tour champion
Hikaru Nakamura and we have linear
Dominguez who just changed his
Federation from Cuba to the US right
actually five players in the US over
2700 now and with the addition of the
current US Champion Sam Shanklin coming
back to try to defend his title against
like he said there's some of the
strongest players in the world and Aman
and I were talking about a couple days
ago Jeffrey's
statuses a dark-horse perhaps yeah where
Sam was last year yeah and it's kind of
you've got these five players all over
2,700 and then lurking just behind them
is kind of Jeffrey right he's kind of a
distance himself a little bit from the
lower half of the field I would say but
so he's not quite up to that 2,700 feet
eye level just yet but I mean we've seen
him beat look Wang Liam in this
tournament another fantastic world-class
player and I think in my opinion I think
he's ready to take on some some of these
big names and kind of take them out the
a team will be producing that event it
all starts on March 20th at us chest
champs calm as a 12 player round-robin
and I shouldn't fail to mention that the
US Women's Championship is happening and
at the exact same time Nancy paquete say
will not be defending her title this
year but will it be
Irina crush regaining the title after
like four years man it's she used to win
it every year it's been so long though
ya know of course the the classic Irina
crush and as a Tomsky combo and
dominating the championships for you
know like something like I think ten
years back and forth and then uh all of
a sudden in 2016 we saw an Aussie take
the first title away from them and then
in 2017 I think we saw a subpoena forger
take that title and then not see
actually repeated her championship last
year and so it's been a few years now
for those two players so I'm sure
they're hungry to you know kind of prove
that they belong in those top two rating
places in the United States and that
they deserve to be known as you know the
best female chess players in the United
States it's interesting I was looking at
the rosters for these two fields and in
both fields with the exception of
Dominguez all the players have played in
the respective national championships
before now Dominguez is a world elite
player so he has an asterisk next to his
name he's no stranger it doesn't matter
no these guys and girls are strangers to
this big event and they're gonna be
coming hungry that's for certain
okay now back to our games all right
anything yet by the way yeah we're gonna
be with you until the end I'm gonna be
with you until we have the champs
determined until we have those
interviews and
it looks at this point we might we do
have a move Jeffrey has played at three
all right interesting to see that move
so uh well yeah this is actually just in
anticipation at that for I actually like
this move a lot kind of crazy that I
didn't come up with it myself because it
makes so much sense once you see it so
black wants to play f4 trading off pawns
f3 gives them this extra option of
playing a floor keeping pawns off the
board if you think you're gonna be
tricky and try to Queen and I can simply
come back and now I actually have a
great outpost for my bishop on d5 if
need be so instead of giving the black
king this tempo I might simply just play
Bishop e7 or well no I can't do that
yeah so just Bishop c4 and my bishops
fine on d5 controls this it helps defend
this pawn if I ever need it and this
black King can't go too far of course
because and I can just start pushing my
own pawns maybe not immediately due to
some strange fork here but uh you know
simply like Bishop a2 and this King
would have to come back now but yeah
this is a great way to handle this
endgame I think Geoffrey once again I've
been saying it a lot but now it's
becoming more and more clear that
Geoffrey really is the favorite to win
this endgame I really don't think Reagan
hold this see ya after f3 I guess let's
try and find us some ideas for black
here he might try and push this this
Jeep on now and like I said just getting
these pawns further down the board so
that they can start creating threats
it's it's really the only way I think
where I can generate any any counter
play here but you know as the time ticks
on you know this white King's gonna
activate itself why it's eventually
going to coordinate his pieces and yeah
for example if something like this were
to happen
you know White's gonna try to be
creating a passed pawn here I think and
so let's try and find some way for him
to make that a reality right of course
black is not gonna want to play f4
because it does give them this past pawn
but it's tough to entirely prevent it I
think let's see so if it were white to
move here what do I want to play it what
does g3 do anything
yeah g3 is an interesting waiting move
if you know something like h4 were to
happen that's my only kind of concern
here I guess you know we could take this
and then I actually just bring this came
over and I think this would be quite
good for for white here I'm not sure if
we can actually win this pawn which is
kind of incredible because if I were to
play Bishop f7 here trying to prevent
this king from defending this pawn I
could play King f6 and then I would have
to retreat this Bishop I guess there is
this f4 idea with a bishop f7 Oh looks
like we have a result Kerala has
defeated by ginchy Wow but you know it's
not - such a bad deal for by G&G who has
solidified his his championship victory
in Group B so we'll be talking to him in
just to keep it all right yeah it's
actually a very interesting way that
Christian did find this mate here take a
look yeah I was talking about maybe
doing some kind of King g6 idea here
with the idea bringing the shirt to the
a drink but the way Christian handled it
was actually very nice so very common a
mating pattern I think it has a name but
I can't think of it off the top of my
head but it revolves around bringing
this knight back into the game and after
Knight g6 quite simply gonna bring this
King to h6 in the search to g7 and that
will be checkmate this night covering
the kings to flight squares and the
route covering the rest so no way to
stop that four by shaji but like you
said you know a very good tournament he
ends up plus three despite losing in the
groans and definitely happy to take home
that that first-place prize and shout
out to well not just the 2018 North
American champion by ginchy who now is
the group B sprinkle chess Classic
champion but also Kristen korilla for
that great game gorilla of course is
going into the fall as the new coach of
our the coach of the brand new Russian
Satanism chess team it'll definitely be
interesting to see what he does with
that program you know even more stellar
chess programs coming to st. Louis it's
it's nice to see you know well at least
in the area
misoo is about two hours away but on the
very edge of the metro area it's only
about one hour yeah yeah so yeah I mean
it's just
Missouri's a great place for chess I
guess you know one of those strongest
states in the country all right well
let's let's see if anything else has
happened in well I know me Stanton Donna
is still going on in Group B but our big
big matchup don't want to miss anything
I don't know if we will though strong
versus Rob said yeah let's take a look
at their they're taking their time here
okay said you know at the beginning of
these end games that's when these these
strong players with you know the crazy
ability to calculate and to visualize
they really they kind of see everything
through to the end before they make any
decisions so I'm right I'm sure ray was
considering this f3 move and he's just
deciding the best way to try and create
some chances to trade off all these
pawns to get that drawn endgame we'll
take a look at that in just a moment I'm
gonna bow out it because by June she is
here for his championship interview all
right so I'll be back in a moment
okay so yet again looking at this
endgame
I keep saying I think that Geoffrey
Zhang is gonna win it but it is gonna be
really tough to find a way to create a
passed pawn that's really what
Geoffrey's looking to do here let's see
one idea I think might be to bring this
King around let's just play a few moves
here
and then uh sorry not King D - but maybe
King D 3 and maybe an e for push and
this would be definitely an interesting
way to create some chances for white
you know black obviously doesn't have to
be quite so cooperative but this is one
way I kind of see this game ending is
with this this pawn becoming past and
kind of getting through to the ends
let's take another look at this game
that Christian just played with the
Bison cheek and yeah let's go all the
way back to the beginning maybe and
let's see it wasn't exchange love like
we talked about and all right I think
we're about ready here we have bison she
joining me uh thanks for coming in and
joining me not such a great last round
but you know definitely a phenomenal
tournament and you definitely should be
walking home happy with with the first
place title yeah so what are your
thoughts on the tournament in general
how do you think it went yeah this is I
think I was I would bit lucky at some
games and I won I won this but I for the
first five rounds I played very well but
then this three draws and the loss right
that's yeah I felt like we were looking
at your games throughout the whole
tournament obviously and we thought that
you were never really in any danger in
any of games up until today of course
yeah so do you ever feel like you were
being pressed or where under any
pressure throughout the tournament
besides the SAS drums
I don't know how to say I think
basically is
so ya know you're totally fine
yeah definitely some tough competitors
though right you know you definitely had
to fight hard to get those points that
you got yeah definitely not trying to
say anything about that but so what do
you think of today's game today
yeah he had a great opening preparation
ah gotcha is do you want to take me
through here
where were you out of prep so I didn't
prepare this this line today okay yeah
so 95 yep you need for Bishop d7 22 6 so
this is all pretty well-known theory
right and then this is a ch3 move is
this still theory this one I I wasn't as
familiar with yeah yeah I know this move
I got it's prevent I did 95 of course to
save the bishop so a Trixie 8 on the
Queen
yeah a knight of 3d 583 yeah actually
now I'm not sure about castle and Asics
idea I think the the most liver is 94
here okay maybe you might have some
advantage all right and why would you
say that what why why does why have an
advantage sure yeah because there's no
weakness for white okay he can improve
his position slowly it's just like
really two rooks you won it just going
to your xt-1 and casting himself maybe
yeah so yeah castles instead white
simply castles right yeah you played a
six and it's dealing with this pump 95
and so yeah yeah I think here maybe
Bishop EA's p8 is the best option
instead of h6 I'm sorry
h6 first okay then Queen to Bishop yeah
here okay
and threat to play 97x movement that's
not a threat but okay just want to play
thank you sir right let's change the you
5/9 sure yeah just get the strong piece
out of here
yeah and Queen b6 then move later my
Queens out of play so I have to back to
d8 again this might be the moment where
you know things started going wrong okay
so yeah Queen b6
I guess we're anticipating this g4 push
already trying to open the king yeah
this this is a good move okay so you did
go with Bishop e8 right yeah and my
opponent said maybe here this 4 is
better better than g5 but okay yeah it
certainly seemed to work out well in the
game did you think maybe just too many
pieces got traded
after g5 yes yes maybe yeah I think g5
is good enough okay yeah because I
didn't notice that gave you this 97 idea
trading off more pieces after Queen to
d8 yeah and maybe was that what he was
worried about it was there something
else
yeah I thought after 97 that should be
fine but still after some moves I
realized that what I had a serious
pressure right okay yes so you know we
saw this pressure on the G file right
yeah maybe I can I could improve some
we're at Ruby 76 but I'm not sure Rick
what's your that what should I do
yeah it seems tough right just have to
deal with this pressure on g7 the whole
game yes
find a way to improve this Bishop right
but yeah so we did see things go wrong
eventually but I did want to get your
thoughts on on the rest of the
tournament and I still so were you
keeping a close eye on Aundre vegetable
it's game today to see you know what was
going on there because he was the only
competitor of course I can catch last
round so when I'm about to lose I just
keep attention it's their games yeah so
any any thoughts on the tournament in
general any games that you thought
didn't go as well or games that you're
particularly happy with yeah I'm happy
with my game before from the first five
five rounds and after even round six in
round 7 I both have great chance to win
but ah right yeah I think I I should
keep keep playing yeah I choose some
sometimes perpetuate that's not a new
thing already with you know the
breakaway score you were away from the
pack already so just taking some drugs
to kind of secure yeah tournament win
maybe but I don't think anyone could
blame you I did want to get your
thoughts on this end game with Jeffery
going here okay so we just saw it
meaningful light yeah he's definitely a
you know taking his time though any
chances for a to try to hold this any
way to trade off some pawns here or is
this just kind of a dead loss do you
think I think um no I didn't see a way
to draw here because yeah that's not the
H planet if H one is there like an
sector fact everything else in writers
right old form yeah ending up with the
wrong color but yes there was the
classic way to uh to try and draw this
what that how is white going to win
though what's what's the winning plan
here
I'm not sure I think both be foreign
King f2 swimming it seems but sure I'm
not so sure
say maybe e4 and then uh how does white
eventually you know push further though
how does he get this pawn up the board
or how does he stop you know this is the
safe home I think that's going to play
g5 age five in chief or maybe in the
addition and try to create a new
passport right but oh yeah that's maybe
that's there is some problem for life so
lame yeah King that too
sure and then uh I'll do you think we'd
see a trade of puns or maybe just g5 I
think maybe g5
yeah this was the problem I kept running
into is I kept saying it should just be
completely winning but then it's yeah do
what has to play well yeah so maybe it's
some chances for black to draw yeah I
guess so all right well congratulations
again it was great having you here in
the studio
you know Spring Classic champion how
does it feel it's a great tournament all
right I feel it man nice yeah yeah we're
glad to have you at the club and we'll
hope to have you back here again that's
the Asia yeah congratulations again
thanks for joining me here in the studio
thank you so much yeah it's good that's
bison she talking with us after his
tournament victory champion of the 2019
spring classic B group and so that does
leave us with just these last two games
going this game with Jeffrey Zhong and
Ray Robson of course going to determine
the a group the eight groups fate this
is the current position we have on the
board we did see this king F to move
that by suggested and after a three
Bishop c4 to stop this pawn and he's
yeah white is just up this full piece
but it's not so easy apparently to find
a winning plan I thought it might just
be my failing but turns out you can see
some good chef's players are having some
difficulty finding a way to break
through here right and it really gets me
thinking Caleb that this might be one of
those situations where if you're on us
chess champs calm and you see the chest
24 meter and you're like oh yeah
Jeffrey's one is the engine fooled well
you can never really trust when the
engine says here unless it says
something like zero zero zero or
something like plus ninety nine because
in reality those are the only two
correct evaluations an evaluation like
plus three here it doesn't really make
any sense because either White's winning
or he's not right there's no kind of
in-between you know there's like plus
three worth of chances here
so either White's gonna be able to queen
this pun or he's not and so stockfish is
saying something like plus three then
that means it doesn't know either it
just sees that okay whites up a bishop
whites plus three it's kind of simple as
material counts sometimes so yeah like
if I was saying of this g5 g4 idea with
h5 included trading off these pawns it's
kind of tough to prevent and it'll be
interesting to see what Geoffrey comes
up with here
seems like Ray's play is going to be
very natural as as the holding side
right you just want to push these pawns
it's kind of what I've been saying but I
really can't come up with it for
Geoffrey if I'm being honest with you it
seems absurd to have this extra bishop
and not be able to handle these three
pawns but maybe some difficulty maybe
some difficulty well let's talk about
our situations here because if one of
these players wins of course they are
the group a champion of the spring
Classic but if this is a draw then the
players will go to a three-way playoff
with Iliad News Nick and that's going to
occur at 5 p.m. Central Time just about
two hours from now it should be done
within an hour but they're gonna play a
three-way rapid round-robin with a game
intend control and if that does not
determinate an outright winner then all
three of them will then play a blitz
round-robin race and then if that does
not determine a overall winner clearly
then they will go to a series of
Armageddon games so just to clarify it
with that but you say if the Round Rock
the rapid round robin does not determine
a winner so that could mean that only
two players are tied and one player is
trailing but then that last player would
get another chance right in the right
surround Robin yeah it's really
important how its worded the regulations
aren't posted on US chess champs calm
but it's using the same regulations of
the winter chess classic so if you go to
that event you can read them for
yourself on US chess champs calm the
terminology very important if it does
not produce a winner mm-hmm then the
three of them will go on to the next
stage all right so there you go
maybe we should hope Geoffrey doesn't
find a way
this game that sounds like sighs we get
I see the chaos as something entirely
exciting yes
wrap it around Robin let's check in with
our YouTube chat they've been very
active today Christian korilla who may
be the actual real Christian korilla
says leave it where Zaman where is a
month
well a Mon is has other duties right now
around the club but rumor has it that if
we go to a playoff he will be joining it
that's right I think he will be
available and yeah that's the last you
guys and see of me unfortunately I would
like to get the band back together for
one last time Aditya Chandra says hello
Ben Caleb good to see Joshua post Emma
says Robson has been a defensive wizard
this tournament that's true he's he's
really helps in tough positions and he's
he's managed to turn a few around I
think although I don't think anyway
surgery Ray's pulling off here it can
compared to the wizardry of our own
Christian trilla in round 7 you know
finding multiple stalemate tricks and in
order to save that game down a full rook
was really a something-something to see
yeah Patrick Daly is is kind of joining
in on what we were just talking about
with the computer evaluation he says as
far as this position Leela hates it
stockfish loves it and you know it's
either a win or it's not that's true you
know there's there's no in-between here
you know that's something nice about I'm
getting since you know there's
somebody's right you know somebody's
right in somebody's wrong there's
there's no like opening evaluation white
is slightly better here it's you're
winning
or you're not but unfortunately we don't
have ten player ten ten pieced it and
game cable but if only only we had those
32 piece databases that would be the one
I'm waiting for
yeah okay well let's look over at Group
B Alexander barista and Gregory cat
Donnell that's our only other game still
happening yeah so the last game for for
Group B is this other game is of course
going in a group a weight has made
significant progress here
we do see blacks still trying to hold on
using these two pawns to stop whites
three but it's gonna be tough let's see
what black can come up with here
something white can try maybe
immediately maybe later on it's gonna be
this g4 break to try to shake loose some
of these pawns on the Kings side of
course black would want to take this
pawn and after Knight takes now the idea
for white is gonna be kind of driving
this King away and then pushing through
with one of these pawns and you know if
white can't achieve this past pawn then
he's likely going to be winning just
like in this other endgame you know all
white needs to win is just make a passed
pawn and be able to you know push it
down the board I almost think this one
is slightly gonna be more simple for
white to try to win not to say that you
know it's it's a definite win here I
haven't calculated out to the ends but
it looks as though it's not gonna be too
difficult to make this past pawn and
once he gets that passed pawn it's
really gonna be tough for black to hold
on we might see something like Bishop d2
then after Ned h6 again pushing this
King away we would see maybe King g4 but
I've run into some trouble here with my
knight so maybe it's not as clear how to
get this King up to g4 maybe I would
have to play King efore instead but yeah
now you know this pawn is also being
left behind so always these these
technical problems when you're trying to
you of course defeat a very strong
Grandmaster you know that they find all
these little ways to just make
everything annoying right nothing is
ever as simple as it seems I think your
knight h6 and then King g4 plan would
still work I mean if the bishop um you
could bring the King up to g5 right and
protect it uh yeah we might run into
some issues there actually a king g5
maybe this Bishop takes off for move
might be working I mean do you have
enough time to go and eat away the other
pawns on the Queen
I don't know you can't go right away
because you have to be careful there was
black skin a queen
I think simpler for white is actually
going to be this 93 move here I'm pretty
sure this King and ponen game would be
completely winning due to f5 here
you can't play g5 because white would
just queen and if you take my king is
gonna be faster than yours just barely
and so you know of course that means
black can't trade here and then after
something like King f6
we could actually see you know white
make some advancements with this King
maybe come and take these pawns in the
Queen side either way you know still
some some ideas for black here it's not
trivial but we do actually see this g4
move on the board so white is angling
for positions like this and we'll see
what he comes up with here I think we
see yeah
politics and I takes both both on the
board so it's gonna be interesting to
see you know what black comes up with
how he tries to keep these pawns from
getting rolling and how why it tries to
you know keep these pawns under control
and maybe make a passed pawn or go after
these Queen side pawns both seem like
viable plans to my eyes okay well before
we talk about some great upcoming
programming on the st. Louis Chess Club
YouTube channel let's glance back at our
big one sure our and see if anything has
happened and looks like no moves have
been nothing no moves we are inching
closer and closer towards the time when
the players won't have the ability to
stop making moves with Rey only with
eight minutes left and Geoffrey sitting
on a cool sixteen so I really do think
that plan that bison she was mentioning
with this g5 this H 5 and this g4 that's
gonna be the way for black to continue
here I guess Rey is just considering you
know what the best order to push these
pawns is in or maybe he's just thinking
alright I know what I'm gonna do but I
want to have
you know planning for the future I want
to know what its gonna do I want to be
ready to you know kind of just blitz off
the rest of this end game if need be the
heat could be really be turned up on
this in a second you know
well ya know let's just give it like
another half a head and and then it'll
be Wow well yeah it's true loser moves
are gonna start flying so let's try make
some predictions here I really do think
we're gonna see a move like g5 or h5
I'll start with g5 for example and now
like I said the onus is really on
Geoffrey here he's got to find a way to
break through and maybe one problem that
Ray's finding with g5 is something like
g4 trying to prevent this h5 move again
stopping two pawns with one but I think
interested see the this endgame actually
I'm not sure this is what Geoffrey wants
to go for it does give them this this
backward pawn and that means you're
gonna have to trade even more in order
to you know make any progress
so g4 probably not the idea maybe just
bringing this king of rounds but once
again this plan is difficult to stop
difficult to stop it seems as though
eventually we're gonna have to play the
C form move that you know bison she was
shying away from at first when he was
giving us his you know his his take on
this endgame but yeah if I'm if I'm
being entirely honest I really don't see
it really really don't see it let's go
ahead and try efore now if we see h5
maybe you know like white can waste some
time here we might see g4 and you know
if white isn't careful we might see
something like this happen
and then of course you know h4 and if
this King ever straights too far away
now
now suddenly h3 will come through in g2
g1 and so this is kind of what blacks
aiming for I think it's kind of a kind
of like a fortress because you know the
king the King would states have added to
g2 and then the black king would come in
and just go back and forth with the
white bishop in the on the queenside
corner is that right uh yep so of course
no black really can't try to make any
progress here because of this black hole
straight away okay you know well Queen
but so yeah I really don't see a way for
white to try and make any progress here
if you try to play let's say King D for
King f1 King here you know maybe I mean
like the only thing would be let's see
him let me just maneuver my way to this
position
the only thing would be to try to
replace this king with this bishop but
there's there's no real way to achieve
that because as soon as this bishop
comes here you know this pawn can always
try and Queen once this Bishop you know
vacates is diagonal so if something like
this were to occur I think this is just
dead drawn so Jeffery definitely really
does have to find something here again
this move g4 I really don't like it dude
due to this happening but maybe this
does give more chances for white to try
and break through we might see something
like h6 and after a pass you know now
white can suddenly try and make some
progress here right black might be able
to trade off another pawn but in my
opinion what's going on here alright
yeah I don't think this is enough I
think the Sun game is drawn the specific
position we have on the board yeah so I
kind of be expecting Jeffery to be in
the tank here thinking about these ideas
I wonder what Ray is worried about
that's stopping him from just going for
this g5 h 5g for plan what that thing
said and now Ray's down to four minutes
yeah I'm not ready to give up for a
white just yet cuz it really is annoying
it's annoying that I'm up this full
Bishop and I can't find some way to to
break through here okay and there is H 5
H 5 on the board so a very similar idea
he still wants to point g5 g for
probably g3 I think is is a fine idea
because I think that position is
definitely drawn
I'm not sure if that's the idea right he
hasn't minds but that definitely be what
I was thinking about one idea I haven't
mentioned for Jeffery is this g3 move
this might be interesting and so the
difference here from a move like g4 that
I was talking about is that it wouldn't
leave you saddled with this backward
pawn now the coupons on h5 though of
course this would be different entirely
but uh I'll move like g3 kind of keeping
your pawns fluid it's kind of a benefit
here in these end games we might see
black capture one of these pawns I'm not
entirely sure maybe just g5 instead
trying to keep the keep the tension but
of course you know white always has this
option of just kind of passing with the
bishop so you might see actually maybe a
yeah bishop a to hang out five let's see
I'm gonna try and get it with my bishop
so Bishop e3 king of five and then maybe
like a bishop b1 keeping this King out
of f5 and now you know blight kind of
has to make a decision here I can't
really back off cuz then Geoffrey can
can capture here and with these two
pawns I think that should be enough to
win because the way these n games kind
of work is this pawn is worth one of
these pawns right you can always force
this bishop away and then take one of
these pawns
you know if if need be but you can't
really take both pawns right you can
imagine like so they put the put the pun
on h5 does that make a difference yes
and no you can imagine something like h4
King G to happens right and now like I
said this pawn is worth one of these you
know you can play this and come take
this guy but the thing is it's not worth
both right because the bishop now has
time to come back into the game that's
kind of what I was trying to say there
is it gains you some time to play a two
and sacrifice that guy but not enough
time to take both pawns usually so that
situation you think would be a draw or
what that final situation this this
would be a win for white definitely I'm
not so yet King g5 defending this fun we
would pass and then simply have four
takes let's go back here though so of
course you know black doesn't have to go
away but this might actually force black
to capture on one of these two squares
now let's try capturing an e3 for black
and now I know what with this pawn
structure I'm really again not sure how
Geoffrey wants to kind of break through
here because if he's not careful
I think blacks just gonna play h4 and
you know only one mom on the board like
I said generally this pawn is gonna be
worth one poem on the side of the board
he's gonna be able to sacrifice this
pawn in order to use this King to to
capture this guy so if something like
this were to happen now I think this
would definitely be that draw that we
were talking about simply no way to
break through for my I think so those
are a lot of different plans for white
in the Sun game but I can't find a win
in any of them no Geoffrey of course a
much stronger chess player than I so
maybe he'll be able to pull it off but I
gotta tell you I'm really really
struggling to to come up with anything
for white here I think what we we might
end up doing is
taking a break until there's some kind
of a change in this breakthrough or
something well we'll get to that in just
a moment but if you're watching on the
YouTube channel you might want to open
us chess champs calm and see the board
for yourself don't trust the eval but if
you're on youtube you also wanted you to
you want to just it's been a long you
want to subscribe is what I'm trying to
say you want to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and join the 206 thousand other
people across the world that have made
us one of the top chess
youtube channels in the world and we are
now doing something really exciting on
the channel we have begun to stream our
lectures live and it's been a process it
was very imperfect at the beginning but
now it looks pretty much like the edited
product ya know you've done one or two
live lectures I think I've done two now
one wrote to 2001 I was also filling in
for right then I believe but yes it's
been a pleasure it's great to be able to
you know interact with the YouTube chat
you know live as you know the lecture is
happening and yeah I'm having a lot of
fun with it I think the YouTube oh yeah
booze we do say yes I think the YouTube
chat is also having a lot of fun with
the live lectures okay yeah yeah Jeffrey
is actually committed to a very big
decision after h5 he only thought for
four minutes on each takes at 4:00 and
now he's actually going to get that pawn
structure I was just looking at after
something like King to f5 if King to e3
we're going to get this to on to pawn
structure and yeah this is one of the
ones I I couldn't find a way through for
white but you know I've got a lot of
faith in Geoffrey Zhong I think he think
he might might be onto something here
cuz if he thought this was just a draw I
imagine he probably would have taken
more time on his last turn so this is
just a faith issue here you you still
don't see it yes blind faith in Jeffries
you know else
my analysis in my evaluation of this
position with that of Mines I mean okay
you don't have to be a great chess
player to see raze down to three minutes
clearly he was saying something he
didn't like Jeffery again only taking
four minutes on making this super
committal decision I'm thinking he's
pretty confident here and even just
looking at the body language you know
it's always tough to tell with Jeffery
but he's always so composed you know
he's he's looking at the board he
doesn't seem to be you know he doesn't
seem to have you know any doubts about
his position and Ray hunched over really
looking looking for those moves and so
yeah
blind faith and Jeffrey well Jeffrey's
composure has really changed just a few
minutes ago
he sat down at the board and he was
rubbing his eyes like he just got out of
bed like oh man you got to think he
maybe maybe it was going through his
head I don't see a win but now he does
look more determined he looks very
focused he's not rubbing his eyes it
couldn't be more different than how it
was just a few and it's definitely some
uncertainty from right there hovering
over the king with his hand of them
pulling it back this is what it's all
about it raised down to two and a half
minutes with the thirty second increment
of course it's got to make a decision
and it's something about these in games
is also you know one wrong King move can
can spell disaster simply you know UH
one square it's slightly misplaced maybe
it's being on the light square and
getting checked by the bishop or the
dark square and allowing f4 with tempo
but so yeah it's it's every move can be
an important decision so definitely
some complications for rates it to be
careful of here she kind of explains why
he's taking so much time
now if someone's going to win we know it
would be Geoffrey mhm
do you see any kind of possibility where
Ray offers a draw uh not really at this
love them though even even at my level
which is kind of you know the still
amateur tournament player when you're in
the worst position when you know that
you're holding the position even if you
think it's completely drawn if you know
that you're on the technically worst
side you never offer the draw it's kind
of impolite because the understanding is
both you and your opponent understand
you know the dynamic you're holding he's
pressing so when he's ready to draw
you know he'll offer you but the draw
it's yeah it's just kind of seen as
impolite in my experience but especially
at this top level I don't think that
ever really happens yeah so the players
getting some news about the Mystica
Donald game the last game yes it is over
Alexander Mistah has defeated the u.s.
legend Gregory kite Donna all right take
a glance at that game we actually saw
both of these pawns break through we're
talking about maybe white making one
passed pawn oh right let's get that
board up on the screen if we can yeah
there it is yeah we left off around this
g4 break again you know breaking down
this structure that was holding whites
pawns back and so after take sticks we
saw this pawn come under attack
93 check and King g4 to defend it you
know we saw King f6 and simply Knight d5
and we saw this Knight maneuver around
this King get in attacking this pawn and
after Knight to e5 once again this pawn
being on a light square leaves this
Bishop completely helpless to try to
defend it which is what led to Knight
takes c6 and after it takes takes we
just see these two passed pawns
definitely no way to stop those four
black and the game quickly concluded
after h5 h6
and you know that no way for black to
hold on so great showing from Alexander
Mistah you know really technically
converting that that endgame it's good
to see and now since all of the games
have ended in Group B and in fact they
were all decisive yeah let's take a look
at our final standings for our
challengers division well we know that
our champion is by ginchy with a with a
total score of six points even though he
couldn't walk away with the win and a
final round I wish we kind of would have
opened up the other I should have opened
up the other round so we're like hey
show us your favorite today we don't
want to look at today
ya know kind of an unfortunate game you
know well played by Christian notes
especially in that that final positions
there to find the me and Alexander
mister actually coming up to second
place only 1/2 point behind with this
win in the last round
yeah and it's a half point behind that's
$1,500 less but not too shabby for our
polish player who leaves with $2,500 and
then third place clear third is the
former B champion Andre Irish poets who
leaves with $2,000 and the prize
breakdown is available at u.s. chess
champs calm no one is walking away
empty-handed so it's worth everybody's
time it indeed there's only one game
left only a one game well shipping and
it determines whether we're gonna be
here for about another two to three
hours and I do have something funny I
want to show you been go for in this
chess board so if we can get it back up
on the screen alright so one way I think
Geoffrey would have liked to see this
game go would have been g3 check King g5
f 4 check and then then I'll leave it to
you to find the win here
okay hold on I'm holding okay Bishop e6
checkmate checkmate
oh it's deafness would have loved to see
that but you know of course grace not
gonna do that
you know chess is never quite as easy as
we would like so of course you know raid
doesn't even go to g5 he comes to f5
with this game no chance to even check
this King anymore so after that we saw
Bishop a to happen
from c4 that we should be retreated to
a2 and its back on to raise move with
only two minutes remaining so he's
really got a you know he's got a commit
to a plan and kind of stick to it now
that he doesn't have much more time to
really be thinking about these things
our chant it look guys this is awesome
we have almost 500 people watching right
now which is more than we had whenever
there were more games going on so it's
heating up and Arthur Tang says
Jeffrey's trying but Ray is pressured to
find the best resource I think that is a
fair assessment yeah a lot of pressure
on your a whereas you know Geoffrey can
kind of take his time here I think you
know one of our most prolific commenters
Patrick Daly says I understand the
fundamentals but I don't know what to
calculate I don't understand the
position yeah you and me both
I've I feel as though like I've
calculated through every possible way
for a way to try to win this and I'm
just really not saying it but you know
these on games can always be tricky you
know it's a matter of faith I guess it's
a matter of faith in Geoffrey we do see
g5 from Ray now so he has committed to
pushing this pawn to one square further
and I think you know we might approach
an endgame like this let me just play
move for white here and then if h4 were
to happen I really think that this is
that this is a draw so does white have
any other options here after age 4 maybe
we might see a g4 push and after a king
out form in the of the ship d5 okay
maybe you know some
clever way to pass the time but yeah I
really think that this is gonna be a
draw
even after something like H 3 and H 2
you know black can play a queen take
sticks and now after a 2 I will start
maybe white would defend this pawn and
then after a 2 we would see this draw so
I really don't see any options here for
white if he were to allow this h4 move
to happen which means you know Geoffrey
if he's gonna do something has to do
something right now and we actually saw
King III played very very quickly from
Geoffrey and so now if h4 maybe he's
planning something that I don't see
I really think his only two options are
to take and to push I don't think
anything else could could really happen
here I guess he can play something like
King to f2 Ray's just played king e5
yeah so P if I'm not going for h4 which
is interesting I really thought h4 was a
great way for black try to draw this hmm
but maybe a you know keeping keeping the
the pawns kind of in flux here is is
also going to be okay this should be won
by Geoffrey so we see you know the
players may be gaining some time on the
clock now although you know the more I
look at it but further away those Kings
being pushed
you know Geoffrey is almost kind of
using using some mysterious power to get
this King farther away from his pawn
well yeah I can't go back to f5 anymore
yeah see you guys right down to
40-something seconds it's really tight
here just the king going back to f6
change anything
well think about retreating that way is
you know maybe white can start playing
things like King e for and you know
waitis isn't careful then you know this
h4 move is going to come but you know
allowing the king up is always gonna be
a danger it would be a danger for for uh
you know black
and we do see King f6
and now of course you know Geoffrey will
demonstrate his winning idea that no one
here can see this amazing kingi for a
very faithful move you start to wonder
about f4 here as well you know if you
know black ready to capture white could
capture back and now like I said though
this H bone in this a pawn together are
gonna force you know the king and the
bishop respectively to kind of abandon
this pawn wouldn't you rather take on f4
with the king though takes with the king
well then I was thinking h4 here for
black and you have to play g4 so of
course if you were to take this pawn I
can put my king here and the game is a
draw because this is the wrong color
Brooke pawn for this Bishop but if you
were to play g4 now I can push even
further with h3 and you can play g5
check and then come take this fun but
like I said these two pawns together
kind of force the white pieces to
abandon this pawn kind of leave it in
the dust
although mmm all of a sudden I think I
might see the idea this would be a very
interesting way to keep this game going
and I think this yeah the same game
should just be completely wedding I'm
completely missed this idea of bringing
this bishop back to that makes all the
difference doesn't it yes so how with
this new idea maybe this is going to
factor into the game somehow we do see
more who's being played we saw it this
actually King F King a fourth that I
mentioned and we saw let's see so kingi
for King e6 Bishop a2 and now ray to
move I would predict the King comes back
to f6 if I had to guess
well if you're just if you're one of the
new folks who has just joined us you're
watching the 2019 spring chess classic
final round final game possibly going
into playoffs but we might have a clear
winner here Ben Simon and Caleb Denby
with the call Grandmaster Oman Hamilton
will join us later for playoffs if
necessary
yeah and Geoffrey's really playing with
a lot of confidence he's playing really
quickly but I tell ya I have yet to be
convinced of the win here yeah we do see
came back to f6 and then I will see
Bishop III it looks like from white so
whoops what happened here okay here we
go
see if Bishop e3 once again using this
Bishop to mark time such that you know
the black King has to go even further
away and so it's starting to become kind
of awkward for right he does have to be
quite careful the further this King
comes up the board you know the more
kind of convinced I am that Geoffrey
knows what he's doing
we see King to g6 played I would imagine
king e5 is the idea now but like I said
you do have to be careful of this H pawn
so we do see king e5
black has to find a move this is why I
thought and bh4 would be played right
away well the White King was still kind
of passive back on f2 now the Kings up
on e5 I think white might have some more
options
you can't play something like King h6
because of course King f5 then would
just be completely winning the game
first King h6 King f5 and then you have
no moves with the King so you would have
to push this fun and then of course you
know the White King can come and Corral
this pawn and be in time to defend this
F pawn if we were to see something like
age 4 maybe would see takes takes and
now of course white does have to kind of
deal with this pawn I don't think he has
time to just run up the board and so
this is something that I was you know
kind of still thinking about maybe not
King f6 maybe an h3 move but now it
seems as though it's just too late it's
just too late for right so I'm not sure
what the idea was you know originally to
prevent this kind of endgame from
happening but it it seems like Geoffrey
is just winning now I think I'm finally
convinced both on the board and in my
heart that Geoffrey is winning this game
well it's good to know ya King age 6
yeah this is I think we saw King f5 King
aged six and now once again I'm
predicting Geoffrey will just mark time
and after h4 we will get the son game
that we were just looking at and this is
this is an optimum this pawn is not only
h-file if it were it would be a draw but
of course with this pawn being on at f3
you know this is just basic stuff now
yeah yeah breaks down it one actually
one of my favorite basic beginners end
games
yeah the opposition get the pawn to the
right of the board and it's actually you
know almost simpler than that right
because usually in this endgame let's
just say
black to move good to know
you know you get some position like this
maybe and let me put this Bishop here
just for a moment you get a position
like this right and no matter how hard
you try it's always gonna end up being
stalemate right that's it not moving I
think they just shook hands right now
all right the game is over I was gonna
mention of course you know with the
bishop you know you can win that onion
without the bishop it might be a drop if
the king is in front of a pawn but yeah
Geoffrey Zhang our champion now two
times over the seasonal classic group a
champion
see Mike coming over making it official
it's a very important job right there
you got to put them on the right squares
those kings or also won't register the
right result it looks like ray and
Jeffrey are talking about the endgame
now seeing what might have been missed
like they're talking about an age for if
I'm understanding the hand signals
correctly yeah ray looks kind of
dejected I think he feels like he might
have missed something they're gonna have
to get Jeffrey's thoughts on that for
sure on the son game okay well hopefully
he doesn't feel too dejected because he
won a one that he won the tournament no
sorry I'm a feeling great Rogers okay
right okay Jeffrey just looks you know
kind of exhausted Rad's one would be
after it's such a marathon game well
hopefully they can hurry their
post-mortem up because we gotta talk to
Jeffrey Jean at the 2016 world junior
champion still just 18 years old and now
the two-time Spring Classic champion
from the Dallas area
Jeffrey Jean so we'll talk to him
shortly but let's not only a big name in
the future of American chess yeah yeah
and keep an eye out for him at the US
Championship yes in two weeks you never
know what will happen at this event
Sam Shanklin won last year after a good
showing also at the spring chess classic
so let's take a look at our final
standings for our masters division
no playoffs necessary I can't say I
thought this would happen coming into
today I thought hey probably a 60 70
percent chance we're going to playoffs
not so in the group a of course we know
that Jeffrey Zhang is the champion and
he leaves with 4000 I'm pardon me
$6,000 6007 place is Elia nish Nick who
had to sit on the sidelines and hope for
a draw in this last game that did not
happen but he still leaves with 4000
after wonder if maybe he wishes he had
played slightly differently in his game
now to try and really get some chances
yeah for sure yeah absolutely and we
were talking about the players walking
around the hall and looking at those
chances but really that's all it is
you're playing with odds it's and I'm
sure that if you asked me shake well I
don't want to put words in a lot of the
players say no you know I wasn't banking
on it whatever happens happens they're
very zen about it yeah you know let the
fates decide yeah and then of course a
Ray Robson and Liam Lee leave with
$2,500 okay certainly not a bad days
work let's look at our chat while we
wait for our champion to come in to the
studio steamroller 82 looks like he's
just joining us for the first time hold
on that's the Avant shucks it's like the
legendary world-class player Yvan Chuck
yes steamer 182 welcome so the magic
that is the spring chest classic great
to have him here in st. Louis yes yes no
doubt Patrick Daly wants to know when
viewers choice can be viewed well
viewers choice you hosted it last week I
did indeed yes so that's Thursdays every
five six thirty I believe yeah and yeah
that's going to be live on the YouTube
channel for the foreseeable future
yeah so you can be sure to watch that
every Thursday you know tune in ask some
questions live to the Grandmaster
and maybe uh you know I'll have
something to say to you yeah we might
actually kind of tweak the submission
process right now I'll be very candid
with you if you send a game too info at
st. Louis chess club organ st. as
spelled out that's info at st. Louis
chess club that horn and our good friend
Perry Colson will take your games and
put them into a chess based database
yes and then we look at them later so
right now we don't have a protocol for
looking at your games live but that
might change in the future once we
become more accustomed to the process so
it's certainly be interesting it's just
to be able to link a game live in the
chat yeah it'd be pretty chaotic but
right right now though the process is we
try not to look at the games we
disqualify some games because of volume
if they don't have details sure your
name your opponent's name if possible
tell us your story if you're working on
the railroad in India that happened one
time
that's awesome to hear we want to know
about we want to know how you found our
channel we want to know who your
favorite personality is you say hi to
bend feingold everyone always does and
he's not the one looking at the games it
doesn't matter it's always a good time
so yeah check that out once again the
email addresses info at st. Louis chess
club dot org okay well Caleb it's been
just a really fun time and are you happy
or sad we're not going to playoffs uh
mixed bag you know I'm happy for Jeffrey
you know it's great to see him you know
doing well going into the US
Championships I hope to see a great
performance from him definitely you know
it feels like he's he's one of the top
names in the future of American chess so
if he can start taking down these these
Wesley so these are Carter Nakamura's
these Fabiano's you know really push
himself up into the the elites and you
know it all starts here in the spring
Classic you know coming up with the US
Championship it's just ten days away at
us chess champs calm if you can make the
trip to st. Louis for that event there
are some super fans that already do it
you'll be in good company
we're gonna have live commentary at the
kingside diner right actually above us
and the right next door to the Chess
Club and they have great food they're
gonna have the best coffee in town and
for just ten dollars a ticket I believe
a day yeah I believe actually one of the
players in the spring Classic will be
doing that live commentary if I'm not
mistaken is it Eric Hanson we'll be
doing our kingside diner commentary
along with Alejandra Ramirez dream team
and yet it'll be a lot of fun to watch
you'll see a lot of these players back
here again
you know competing this time for maybe
an even greater title than the Spring
Classic champion you maybe I don't know
Spring Classics a pretty big deal Chuck
here fighting for the title yeah yeah
and if you if Hansen and Ramirez aren't
your bag well we do have a big screen
next door at the Chess Club you come by
and watch the gen Yasir and Maurice in
studio a for that commentary and it
lasts 11 days guys 12 with the rest day
come and check out st. Louis and don't
spend all your time in the Central West
End it's fabulous but also an enhanced
Forest Park right next to the
neighborhood but there's so much to do
in st. Louis and you know chess chess
beer and baseball yes that's what I do
that's what that's what st. Louis is
yeah well we're still waiting on an
update to get our champion in the studio
Jeffrey Zhang and hopefully we get him
shortly oh he's so looks like someone
needs to get him out of there this looks
familiar I think we're actually looking
at something like this and yeah this is
the one that I thought might be a draw
cuz yeah keep the six here looks like
ray is thinking about playing it maybe
he oh no okay a lot of hand motions done
I'm not so good at sign language but
yeah I'm gangs like this are some of the
ones that I thought were or John and Oh
suddenly alright the Kings are shifting
the Kings are shifting the bonds are
shifting oh my goodness
know the value of a post-mortem after a
particularly game like this is actually
it would be useful to us when he gets
down here because I'll have that that
foresight coming in to talk that you
only know what's going on and Wow I'm
not sure how they would have achieved
this position I guess they're looking at
what would happen if White had captured
that pawn enough for certainly would
have been interesting yeah we actually
saw two decisive games coming from
exchange slob positions today so maybe
the reputation of that opening is
starting to turn around what are you
what are you gaining from any other
insight from from what they're looking
at on the board uh let's see so yeah I'm
not actually sure how they got here with
white having these these three pawns I
guess they were considering the the
movie takes f4 for white and then
instead of recapturing black could
actually maybe get the King further into
a position here and so uh yeah white
supposed to be using the bishop to
control the f3 pawn as well as you know
keep that a pawn corralled so making use
of you know the bishops long-range you
know capabilities it's definitely
something white would have liked to do
here but yeah I'm not sure of it they
got to the position this looks even more
winning for white to my eyes because you
know he is just up three pawns to two on
that on that Kings side now if you can
get his King into the game especially
that that should be it
I think what they're doing now is
analyzing positions in their heads you
know players like like me strive for but
unfortunately I think we're no match for
these two at being able to you know
evaluate these complicated end games
without even putting it on the board so
to put things in perspective these two
players are two floors up from us and
it's very difficult to get someone into
the tournament hall to actually send
Geoffrey down because this is a big
internationally rated event and as such
you cannot have cellphones in the
tournament hall it's true so if someone
not so easy
contact them up there someone actually
has to walk up there and you know it's a
Sunday it's a beautiful day and we don't
have a lot of personnel here at the club
but yeah we might need to take a short
break here or something and send someone
up ourselves to get the champ because we
certainly need to talk to him and
Jeffrey we going back to the Junior
Championships of old here at the Chess
Club back when Ben and Aviv were hosting
we really seen Geoffrey Jean grow up
here at the club that's true Yanks and
he's become pretty well-spoken
yeah he's a regular here I think I
actually remembers his first interview
and he's kind of very timid talking to
Maurice I think wasn't Maurice it feels
like it was Maurice well for a US
Championship it probably was yeah maybe
but yeah very timid kind of a you know
not so forthcoming and in his analysis
of his game but he's definitely one to
you know talk about his games now and
give us some insight into what he's
thinking and especially what his feeling
during these events because it can very
be it can be very you know
psychologically pressing to be playing
in these huge marathon tournaments where
you know every round is of the utmost
importance and you're right up near the
top and you have to keep playing well in
order to secure that title like like he
did today and so it's definitely
interesting to get his insights and to
you know how he's you know handling all
aspects of this spring Classic
Tournament while we're waiting on the
champ we're talking about some upcoming
programming on the st. Louis Chess Club
YouTube channel one of the items that a
lot of you may not know about there's a
big match coming up on April 12th that's
true and it's gonna be nice true
something I like to call the strongest
expert-level chess match in st. Louis
chess club history so I can talk a
little bit about that go right I might
have some insight into this match it's
actually maybe a match that I am playing
against famed
Jonathan Trance of chess openings
explained and so we've both been doing
quite a bit of prep I feel for this
match
there's gonna be a lot of build up a lot
on the line we're both going to go
all-in I think then it's gonna be the
title of this match as we'll be you know
what the players are doing you know
putting it all on the line I've got to
tell you if I lose this match I don't
think I'm ever going to live down the
the pure shame of it then and I don't
think Jonathan's looking to go go over
easy but hopefully you know I can take
him down come April 12th they're gonna
be playing too rapid games I believe
something around the vicinity of 30 plus
oh and then we're gonna follow that up
with four blitz games and you don't have
any increment or delay in your games I
yet it's not set just yet Ben but the
plan right now is no increment no delay
it's gonna get crazy once we get down to
time scrambles but that's the way it
should be you know I know that you and
Jonathan you know you might have
different ideas about what you want in
this match you guys still have to come
to the bargaining table and sign an
agreement on the format contracts have
not been signed yet
but you know definitely April 12 that's
the day to look out for I will be here
Jonathan will be here
hopefully I'll Shawn Marathi Abadi will
be here doing live commentary over the
match to let you know his thoughts on
you know our expert level chess and
should be a lot of fun oh I heard that
Jonathan is actually training with
grandmasters for this match you know he
might be I've heard rumors but you know
I've got to I've got some people in my
corner as well Ben definitely had Dennis
Larew helping me out doing some training
you know he has some very interesting
ideas on you know the way to to prepare
for a mansions I've gotta admit Ben we
clashed sometimes but we've come through
it now and
you know I'm happy to have gone through
the experience with with Dennis are you
worried because Dennis has actually just
lost publicly live on the YouTube
channel
he lost a blitz bounty which
traditionally was comer playing a small
child the concept has morphed just a
little bit into Dennis playing a
competent opponent but still it's
worrisome right turn into Dennis playing
a medium-sized child will say in Jacob
Sanders and he did actually
unfortunately lose that match in
Armageddon which you know made me lose a
lot of faith and in Venice you know I
really felt like you know if you can't
even be Jacob Sanders how am I gonna be
Jonathan strands with him in my corner
but you know sounds like there's some
trouble in paradise here a little bit
done a little bit you know it's really a
shame to see one of the chess club's
finest go down in such a manner but he
fought hard he thought well he took two
games in the regular event and only lost
in the tiebreaker Armageddon which is
slightly more understandable well hey
Julian Pro laïkó has just joined the
chat all right and he says lol yes yes
Geoffrey Zhong is up to you though then
yeah there's still alright guys oh we're
gonna need to get someone up there and
and pull him away from the board kicking
and screaming at to the middle game oh
and more more grandmasters seem to be
coming over here who is that from behind
I can't even tell you that it's
difficult to say I want to say that
might be Sorkin but no I don't think
it's alright so I understand we do have
our very own Chess Club employee Emily
Trask up for the very important task of
pulling the champion away from the board
and getting him into the student
excellent stuff excellent stuff we can
only you know go on and on and on about
my match for so long that yeah hey good
stuff good stuff alright so he has all
the answers to life
and he'll have all the answers for you
okay but before he gets down here got to
tell you the grand chest or 2019 is
coming up it begins in May the very
first event is the cote d'ivoire rapid
and blitz a brand new event on the tour
is the second and a second annual sea IV
invitational in blitz
I think hyung gaskey and I did last year
is it was a lot of fun I'm sure everyone
was best players in Africa it was
actually a really fun event and this
time is going to be the best players in
the world and that kicks off in May for
more information on that gran chest or
org
okay so we have jeffrey zhang ready
coming here for an interview so we're
gonna bring him in but yeah absolutely
well there's nothing going on in the
hall it's empty yeah I guess I'll just
transition out this way keep it rolling
Kayla
keep it rolling of the tournament hall
yeah that is of course where the players
have been spending the last week and a
half in our beautiful board room with us
and snacks there in the in the kitchen
that you can see but ya know it's it's
been a great time here there's the
supreme classic I think you know the
tournament went pretty smoothly it's
good to see a you know it's all wrapped
up now and all right so yeah joining me
now is Jeffrey Zhang we're getting him
just hooked up here after his big one
and extended porous modem into the game
so yeah how are you feeling Jeffrey
after this this last round I mean
obviously I'm very happy
quite relieved honestly I felt actually
in the turn right I didn't play very
well so I just feel extremely fortunate
to have a good result Wow yeah you did
end up with quite a good score however
but what results on this last game
specifically it looked kind of unclear
for a while even once you got up that
that extra piece whether or not
you could actually win that when that
end game what are your thoughts well
well the thing is I mean out of the
opening I had a very good position if at
one point and then somehow I just didn't
really know what I was doing quickly I
think I just lost most of my advantage
okay but he let me get this ending which
is very which is very pleasant probably
it should be a draw but it's it's not
easy for black Wow
so but yeah once we once we got this
mired piece of anything I I mean I knew
from the beginning that it would be very
messy very unclear and even now after we
played and after we analyzed I still
don't know if it's a winner drunk Wow
all right do you want to take me through
the game yeah jesse was going on so yeah
of course exchange love were you
preparing to play the exchange slob
today did you know that going in if you
know you face something like d5 yeah
right yeah it was the plan but Ian h5
fine I didn't maybe I know this move but
somehow I wasn't ready for it perhaps
the I mean the most critical try is
Queen takes b7 maybe sure but then after
Knight a5 Queen c7 Knight takes F for
probably Queen b8 rook b8 e f and okay
rugby 8 yeah I have apana but I think he
has some good compensation to bishops
definitely definitely I decided to go
for more mild
yeah but after Bishop III uh instead of
Knight G 3 I think you should just play
g5 here
Wow yes so the idea would simply be to
prevent this nation exactly you just
stop Knight h4n he doesn't my bishop has
no square so he doesn't really need to
hurry to take the bishop interesting so
how might white continue here would
there by English be to that should be to
maybe moving this night and an eventual
f3 to give this Bishop f2 or not so much
I think well [ __ ] be to move the knight
forced the knight to this
because okay if it takes one g3 maybe
the structure is good and again if I
take on b7 here it's it's actually a
better version of the other line because
he was Knight a5 Queen c7 Knight g3
Queen d8 I think it takes with King now
okay
King the3 I I feel it's a better version
because he has a five covered now so
there's not even any 95 oh okay so
interesting yet so definitely not gonna
take on yes I wouldn't have going for
this yeah
so yeah instead this 93 movie you know I
was happy to see you guys gave you quite
a bit of pressure on the H file right I
think so because now it's not so easy
for him I think he should have played g5
anyway still I mean just ya know it
seems like a snare h4 move gave you
quite a lot of chances you see a
submission g6 instead which you think is
maybe kind of a huge mistake
because it led to I wasn't sure but i
all i was sure i just like my position
here after night a check or push percent
Bishop d3 c has some some nasty threats
here right yeah yeah the no sang 696
ideas so I think he's forced to go have
fun right and now I spent a long time
here because I I can play something
simple like night of three and it's a
better position but I decided to get a
little bit aggressive with G for a
punishment yes still trying to break
open this diagonal for it for the same
ideas right yeah so if he takes there's
an a g6 but there were two interesting
possibilities so there's a GFI first of
all night of three FG and the ideas
Knight g5 yes and so you having the b7
fun behinds with with a fork if black
were to take here correct and so what do
you think I mean he has two tries but
they both fail so I thought night before
was a trying to attack the bishop to
protect the pawn you know I have quit a
forecheck
ah okay b5 and Bishop takes b5 takes
takes and he can't hang on to everything
right you know the special pink simians
so there's those a [ __ ] p7 mm-hmm
now I wanted gf5 right and if it goes
for fe6
and I sacked the piece but it's hard
because all these pieces are hanging
once again right I thought he should try
to take on u6 take any 37 and
everything's just very loose so it's
hard to defend I mean g7 is also hanging
yeah that makes a lot of sense so we saw
g6 instead right yeah yes we thought
this might be forced I think yeah
probably he had to go g6 cuz I didn't
think the ones work so you took on i-5
took on a5 and now Knight f3 yeah I mean
were you sure on this mover no I wasn't
sure I mean this is the moment where I
mean I thought I was clearly better but
I just completely lost direction it can
I ask you if you consider g4 here I did
consider g4 I thought now Bishop e7 yeah
and then takes on f5 this similar line
right yes page four and here I thought
there is this interesting move rook
takes h4 Iraqis for okay better Queen h4
at Queen d7
okay and yeah I'm not entirely sure
what's going on here
I guess you're down in exchange after
Queen 66 yeah I'm done exchange a half a
couple of pawns I guess but my king is a
bit weak so I'm not sure this is that
clear
all right interesting I thought okay
instead of maybe instead of rook age 40
maybe you should play F G I think this
is what I was looking at mg probably Hg
yes there's some okay Queen B seven yeah
it's also it was a little bit too
unclear for me to enter right definitely
isn't some complicated maybe it was good
yeah I'm not sure so you just decided
Knight f3 instead yes the complications
should be pleasant for you right that's
what I thought but it turned out to be
not so easy because really Bishop d6
right
and originally I actually I didn't want
to cast but I wanted to play something
like night a4 try to attack some attacks
and stuff yeah get get some pressure on
the exactly yeah but I was afraid of f4
after 94 f4 and I thought again it's
getting very messy like Queen b7 night
before and yeah probably it's just
unclear or anything because it takes
thanks yeah interesting one other move
that we are considering here was maybe
this Knight g5 idea I looked at this one
too but Queen g5 mm-hm
maybe seven and Castle again in c6
Queens you to interesting is so although
I guess kini 2 is a good move
but still not clear Bishop g3 okay cuz I
think I have to defend with the H rook
and then I mean he has ideas here right
definitely like rookie a maybe g5 so
yeah quite a few ideas yeah definitely
some complex variations but yet so maybe
these are and in these lines my piece
where some of the chances kind of
slipped away do you think maybe I feel
like yeah something worked for me but I
didn't see it yeah definitely a black
has a lot of you know counter tries so
instead of all that just just kinda
successful but after castles I feel like
my advantage was just slipping away move
by move because somehow I need to put
pressure like he has a lot of weak I
mean d5 is weak and there's some weak
squares but I didn't see how to take
advantage
I mean right resting again if I go
Knight a for there's f4 I mean I was
considering this queen b7 night before
this should be one Fe Fe but like it's
just looks dangerous route big we need
for right there's even Queen e8 yeah
this is I'm in Queenie 7 created with
the double attack ah yes so not possibly
a lot of weaknesses after f4 right yeah
that's why I felt I have to stop that
fortunately 192 Amex lessons but so
maybe you're playing against this Bishop
if I understood correctly that's what I
was trying to do yeah but I think he
played a very optimally just Knight a5
Queen goes back in queen of 6 I'm good I
didn't really see a plan for me because
actually his plan is quite clear he
wants to play g5 some more and it starts
in King side ration yet he's got his
piece of small play straight so yeah I
played Queen a4 which is kind of
desperate actually yeah I don't really
know what it does because you probably
should just plain I see 6 here mm-hmm
and I don't really know what I'm doing
because
okay I plan Queen b3 but he can just
play rook 88 for example and he's
threatening g5 and I actually I think I
already prefer his position now
interesting I just don't know what I can
do there wouldn't be any way to attack
this pawn immediately I don't see it I
mean neither or is an idea can he just
take and take maybe he can yeah yeah you
can yeah so interesting so this I I mean
I really wasn't sure what to do right
yeah but he played nine c4 in studs
night c4 is also fine I think so but
after I go Queen c2 he shouldn't have
gone back I mean he can just play rook a
c8 for example very logical and maybe he
was afraid of B 3 okay but I think he
just goes Bishop a3 because sure I don't
think I can take the night because my
bishop gets trapped like BC 4 DC 4 okay
I thought yeah my bishop just gets
trapped so I didn't even think this way
possible yeah definitely interesting
variation there wouldn't be a rook b1
here trying to variable attack yeah so I
guess he would just pick up the bishop
sure and then maybe because he has I
mean he has Bishop c4 ideas and his
right sure maybe here is good yeah uh
yeah no yet this would definitely be
some interesting stuff that's why yeah I
was very happy when he got wet Knight a5
he just came back instead okay and now
yeah there's the moment where I I think
I made a good practical decision to play
95 okay
yeah so yeah this was an interesting
concept right hey what's your pieces
into to c7 exactly yeah so yeah he's
forced to take take take Queen c7 and
now I'm almost sure that's equal here
but it looks not trivial for for black
yeah definitely a lot of active pieces
right so you played Rick FC 8 and trade
it off one perixx yeah he tried to force
things off with d4
but probably it it put his position as
an instant risk so yeah we got this
forcing line right this is all for
something nice six takes takes takes yes
to play a 5 B 5 and yeah maybe here was
the critical moment we're discussing
briefly Bishop d5 first okay to try to
uncoordinated
I think ripped e6 and mission b7 I guess
yeah and maybe we can get a little bit
more active yeah Ricky Simba 64 yeah it
looks probably not lost but very
unpleasant right understandable yes so
he went for the more forcing line yeah
he played a a four and six
Rigby is forest and Bishop a six yeah
now the point was the point was if he
goes
Bishop d5 now there's rook c8 so right
and Hayek's takes a through Bishop e6
yeah this Bishop e6 move was a cool
tactic yeah and of course the endgame
but more or less I think we were getting
this ending regardless right so yeah
King g77 b7 Bishop d5 yeah there should
be six rook c8 now yeah there was this
idea to try a three Oh interesting
I know this is why I had to kick the
bishop on d5 first okay because the
point is were baa - okay eight he Queens
and Bishop f1 ah yeah because of his
business on d5 he could take on any but
the Queen has to move and then you just
clean yeah interesting line we missed
that one so yeah that's why he has to
give it up I mean there is another way
to give up the piece so instead of
Bishop e6 you could try to take on b7 to
play this one right and then the rooks
t715 f6 I guess Bishop e7 but it's hard
to say I think the one he tried was was
better it was a better option because
okay yeah what the rooks on it should be
easier to keep pipe on I feel it is okay
so yeah he went for the the pure Bishop
down again yeah and this was just really
really hard for me to understand she's a
65 but yeah this was a critical moment
I went wrong yes three yeah I feel I
feel f4 feels of correct right I thought
king b5 Bishop d3 because now I mean
ideally I just try to keep as many pawns
on the board so when I fix a for it
feels like this should be the way I
think I was worried about I was worried
about a three I think yeah so some
forcing this should be one king C for
Bishop a2 is forced kin c3 c3 yeah
here's ones to win the bit right
immediately because I'm not sure this is
winning so I go King F to Team B to
Bishop g8 would say a to take stakes now
I just I just have to be careful but I'm
sure this is there some efore here
that's what I consider him a be4 I
didn't like because there was some line
for example g4 f v 4g b 4f v 4g for i
think i calculated
h5 and maybe i thought this was a draw
interesting about 5 I'm probably
miscalculated because f5 is probably
just winning because I Quinn with check
I mean I may be only calculating ghh f5
and I don't green with checking that's a
draw but I missed fun ok yeah so I mean
this yes camp on anything I should have
worked out it so should be winning so
you chose the more flexible kind of f3
instead right yeah I missed I think I
just didn't understand because I missed
after F for like maybe fail to consider
it because I thought I had efore yeah
giving this passed pawn yeah the
connected passed pawn I thought it
should be winning but it's actually a
dead drop
so you just plays g5
and the point is it's a simply a
fortress once he achieves h5 and g4 he
goes g4 and then he once g3 at g3 and
then H and I can't
yeah that locks the King down to the
king said exact yet this looks pretty
problematic yeah and I mean I realize it
too late so now I had to go king of -
okay I'm a3 Bishop c4 and now we were
analyzing we're analyzing g5 although I
think all the lines are similar because
we're getting the this kind of position
one way or another so let's just
continue for now yes well h5 takes takes
g3 although actually okay let's see so
okay let's okay we'll go let's follow
the game and then return so j-3 King f5
Spade to g5 key three the key point is
if he goes H Ford yeah this is what I
was expecting but the problem is I think
I okay I start with a check this should
be 1 kt v and now i go King f2 because
now the g4 square opened up so I thought
I can just bring the king to g4 and I'm
not sure how he stops me for example
king d4 Kingi to King III and Bishop a2
and I believe it's Dukes 1 because if
you play skini - it's F 4 and the
[ __ ] goes and if he moves the King
away I go KH 3 King g4 right if he plays
let's say H 3 yeah it takes take a three
and move the bish
anywhere and it's lost yes all right
it's always gonna be zooms when for
example King III King G for the King F
to Bishop a to Kim G 2 and just trying
to weigh so Bishop somewhere King movies
ambition T fo right cutting off all this
guy's and that was the issue
yeah constructive stuff cutting this
King off so that's why h4 doesn't work
right okay
well it's actually it's probably lost
because King e5 let's say in the game
right
I just this should be warned so the
problem is if he goes King d5 I think
you have four works now interesting if
he takes I take with King and then pick
up the pawn and there's no if he plays
g4 I go fish bait to and I think I just
bring the king cuz if my King gets that
fun it's easy all right okay and h4
never works
so yeah this I guess it was winning them
I yeah just for my sake I was thinking
about h42 I take on g5 take on g5 takes
and king of three do everything okay so
yeah it takes and the King comes stage
four all right interesting so that's
what maybe this position is already lost
because he can't stop my came from just
going up the board well yeah
so that's right so after King off sex is
a lot easier right okay I think I can
just and then you're always in time to
stop this h4 pun yeah if H was always
just taken carefully
say interesting you wanted to come back
I wanted to come back because this is
what we were trying to figure out is so
yeah I guess after 800 sluicing I think
I'm although I mean it's just very hard
to say but we're analyzing g5 here sure
the idea is now if I take on that for he
goes GF for okay and I I might be wrong
again but I thought this position was a
draw because it just keeps my King in
the box yeah there's one idea that I
thought was kind of interesting here's
maybe this g3 move I know I think g4 is
a better version because genes really
kind of force him to okay no no this one
I thought was pretty it was easily
winning I thought he should take the
other point oh of course it take this
one and h5 and yeah this is actually
kind of we're reaching the critical
position which is like let's say Bishop
a - hmm
King f5 this should be one king e5 at
for sure let's say takes takes
King f6 and yeah this is kind of the
critical position where I think I mean
we didn't see how how white can break
break this fortress the ideas black kind
of just sits yeah and then when I
removed the King here I can never win
the pawn because a toucan yeah so yeah
this would this is maybe the key
position had he sees this he could have
yeah definitely a complicated a lot of
works but yes so overall you think maybe
this h5 move was not the best try hooray
even if the other end games are maybe
not you know totally drone but
regardless g5 was a better try you think
yeah as of now I think h5 was the
Desai's mistake but again the ending is
very unclear on I mean it's it's
possible that all everything that I said
is is wrong right yeah it's very
complicated in game right but yet with
that in mind you know I want to ask you
about the rest of the tournament you
said you didn't think he played as well
but you know you had some very good
scores overall you know any games you
were particularly proud of this event
well my best game was definitely the win
against lee kuan going in
yeah but i mean even that one what
wasn't very clean I mean I had a good
position and probably it was also very
shaky so right and
the the my first win against Bach was
was kind of ridiculous that one was just
really lucky so yeah and there I had
maybe a lot of bad positions that I drew
so that's a yeah I felt just very
fortunate well looking forward to the US
Championships you'll be playing a lot of
chess again very soon you know any big
goals this year any any plans to
actually make a good shot at the title
or the title that might be a bit
ambitious but the main goal for me is to
qualify for the World Cup so I'll need
it I'll just need to put in a good
result yeah awesome well congratulations
again Jeffrey thank you so much for
joining me here in the studio and I wish
you the best of luck and the US
Championships to come thanks
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online - more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the Chess Club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week directly across the
street from the Chess Club is the world
chess Hall of Fame this one-of-a-kind
cultural institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
well everyone it's been quite the ride
welcome back to st. Louis for our
wrap-up of the 2019 spring chess classic
Bensimon here along with Caleb Denby and
Caleb what did you gather from your
interview with the champ Geoffrey Jean
uh yeah I knew going into the interview
that this end game was extremely
complicated and I left feeling the same
way but it sounds like yeah this is far
more complicated than either of us
reckons and even even the top
grandmasters here don't know entirely
what was going on well someone in the
chat was out there
in the next room while you were doing
the interview and you know Geoffrey had
that he was thinking about the position
the entire time you know yes it's kind
of like a faraway gaze and someone said
it looks like he's contemplating life
like existence or something that was
like yeah it's position like that that
might warrant that type of thinking and
contemplation right so let's take one
final glance at our standings first of
all in group a the masters division
Jeffrey Zhang once again your champion
the only two-time seasonal Classic champ
and six grand is his prize and then in
Group B we have a by Jin Chi it will
also finish with six points
he leaves with $4,000 and it was great
hearing from him today as well ok well
that does it for the 2019 spring chess
classic we want to thank the people that
helped us out Emily Trask and Ryan
Chester Tammy Hyde was the streamer and
the world's greatest production B team
Danny matru cavity technical director
and of course Isaac Krantz graphics and
audio man yeah it was great great show
congratulations again to both Jeffrey
and IMG on a well-played tournament
walking away with the title with that in
mind what do we have coming up Ben in
ten days the US Championship that is the
next time we're gonna be with you I
think most most likely we're gonna have
Spanish commentary for that event as
well and you can see it all at us chess
champs dot-com you know that website I
don't know if you could tell by the name
that was invented for the US as you
believed it was yeah and now we use it
for everything so it's great it's
one-stop shop for all the competitive
it's you'll see online thanks everyone
for joining us in the YouTube chat for
Grandmaster Aman Hamilton
he's Caleb Denby my name is Ben Simon
and until the US Championship in ten
days we say so long from the Show Me
State
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you